Okay.
Yeah, it's gonna take me like one game to wake up, so like...
That's all I'm just gonna give it to tell you guys right now.
It'll take me one game to like fully process what's happening.
So...
Oh, I already went... I'm already fucking pre-live, right?
No, well, it's not live yet, because there's still that three-minute shit.
But like, I'm already fucking in it right now.
I'm fucking...
I'm so excited to go.
I'm not gonna lie.
A little bit of slurring on the words.
Yeah, give me an hour.
No, not an hour.
Give me one game.
An hour?!
One game.
One game and I'll wake up.
Yeah, one game.
I'm so used to... I'm so used to this.
I just need one game.
We're gonna shock you, is what's gonna happen.
We're gonna win in the first one.
That'll keep you awake forever.
I'm just gonna be like...
Whoa!
And then I'll be awake.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, what?
Yo!
Doggy's still half-asleep.
Holy shit.
No, I'll be awake.
I'll be okay.
Take me one game.
Rampart, Newcastle Gibby.
Alright, I'm already have it pre-selected.
What's our team number?
We're five.
Nice.
Yo, the stream delay is actually... Oh, God.
It's already starting.
Oh, God.
Don't worry.
We'll be so fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, is this already... Oh, my God.
We're fucking in it already?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, we're so healthy.
She says, oh, she's dying.
I need you to wake up right now.
My streamer kit isn't even on yet.
Tell me when the game select is over.
Doggy, unfortunately, you gotta play Newcastle, Doggy.
My bad.
Okay, and you guys... Okay, and I wasn't the one that's awake.
I tried looking for Newcastle.
I couldn't find it.
I was unprepared.
My fault.
Whoa, I had my guy...
Okay, I've actually pre-selected my guy before we went in here.
But I guess... Fuck me, I guess.
Let's go.
Doggy, you go loot on my yellow.
Gerard, go loot on red ping.
The fuck is the yellow?
Yellow is... Go here, Doggy.
Loot that and then loot the IMC.
Oh, my God.
Now I have to fucking...
The yellow disappeared.
Is there red ping?
Oh, my God.
All right, now I have to figure...
Okay, the first key doesn't count that much, guys.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah, it doesn't count.
It doesn't count.
Warm up.
Okay, let's go in live right now.
Okay, I'll do the dogs, I guess.
Uh, no, no, no.
Don't do dogs.
Oh, okay, well...
Loot the IMC, like this.
Dogs is northbound.
They might fight us.
Okay.
Goodbye, dogs.
Goodbye.
This zone's really rough, I think.
We're going into wall here.
I'll pick you guys up.
We'll have to see where wall goes.
I hear myself.
Okay, that was fucked up.
I heard myself.
Grabbing all my healies, I promise.
I'm doing it right now.
Grabbing a bunch of them.
I learned.
Okay, all right.
So, okay, we're finally live.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to the stream.
Welcome.
Hello, everybody.
We're off to a bad start.
Doki just woke up, and she's really dizzy so much.
I woke up, but I was locked in at least.
At least I was locked in.
Somebody else wasn't locked in at all.
Okay, listen.
No need to throw shade.
Get in the car.
We're getting in the car.
Okay, I have one.
Grab this cache, Doki.
Which one are we right here?
We're going to be zipping up here.
It's going to be really weird.
I need light ammo, if you guys find any.
Is it dangerous using this car?
I don't remember.
Zip up.
Was it left or right for the castle?
It's the shield, cooldown, and speed.
I think it's right.
Switch shield.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, I think it's a wall zone, but we have to hit this console here.
Just come walk with me.
We're going left.
I'm with you.
I think someone's there.
Walk right.
Right side.
87.
130.
It's fine.
Just walk right.
Just follow the shield if you need to.
I don't have a Q now.
They're setting up at that house.
I think we come play bridge for now.
Someone in the open here.
Running.
I think that's the same team.
There's two guys on this left house, one guy on the right.
Can we try catching this guy on the right?
I'm looking.
The console's up top.
Alright.
I'm shizzling.
Wait, wait.
Careful, Doki.
I'm healing inside.
Come out to us, Doki.
Yeah, let me finish healing.
Then I can.
Alright, I'm heading over now.
We want this house on the right.
Can you come up to me, Jerome?
Yeah, you don't need to follow me.
Just follow the flame.
I'm waking up you.
Hit this console, Jerome.
Come run with me.
Come to me.
Hit it from me.
It's fine, it's fine.
Holding!
Don't fail me now!
I'm okay.
Okay, jump down.
I have no Q, by the way.
We want to fight for this care package here.
Just heal up, Doki.
Okay, I'm okay.
Gibby's going for care pack.
My meds...
We can kill this Gibby here.
It's hard.
It's really hard.
Okay, we're just going to give it up.
Run back here.
My meds situation is bad now.
What do you have?
I have three shield cells left.
I think we do.
I'm going to syringe right here first.
And I'm heading over now.
Just run.
Just do the dugs here.
Yeah.
Hey, there's a bunch of healies here.
I'm okay with white meds.
But I really just need shield cells.
Yeah, we'll get cells from the...
I got two here, if you want.
It's fine, it's fine.
We're doing dugs, so...
Yeah.
We want to fight towards the low ground here.
Careful in case someone shows up on the height.
Very possible.
Oh, there's shield cells here.
I'm good now.
Nice.
Oh, there's more.
Careful in case we get walked up on.
We should be good.
I'm good.
I'm not used to playing Newcastle right now.
After yesterday.
Games.
Don't worry about it.
First game doesn't count.
Yeah, you're right.
First game is just we feed.
Okay.
Yeah, we're just testing the waters.
First game is just feeding, dude.
We're just feeding them?
No, no, no.
We're gonna actually do something nice.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm so over it.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Uh-oh.
Okay, we're okay now.
Let's just sit here and play for ring three on wall, actually.
Alright.
Let's go back.
We wanna take this top left house.
And then check if anyone's still there.
You still get this house for free after everything?
Whoa.
We're not in zone.
That's why there's no one here.
Yeah, that makes more sense.
I was like, whoa.
There's literally no one here.
Come with me, Jordan.
Okay.
Should I put a shield?
No, just keep following me.
We're gonna go on top of the bridge again and hit the console.
Okay.
Did it now register or are we gonna do it again?
No, we're doing it again for ring three.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Ping!
Oh my fucking god!
Just hold on good and you should be okay.
You don't wanna keep pressing it.
There we go.
Just come down.
I have a plan here.
We just need to get to our car.
There is someone there.
We just fight.
He's just sitting on the door.
I'm gonna open it.
Kill this Valkyrie on the left.
Shoot him.
I didn't have an angle for this.
120.
He's one.
I don't have an angle here.
I'm bubbling in.
Can you...
We need to go left here.
Can you wall towards the left, Doki?
Just get a Newcastle wall down.
Nice.
I should be able...
I blocked the grenades.
I'm bubbling in two seconds.
I died.
Can you res me, Doki?
I'm resing, but they're heavy pushing now.
They're pushing.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
That's fine.
First game doesn't matter.
I was uncomfortable with Newcastle there.
Oh, man.
Wait, did they get pushed by another team already?
Wait, what?
There's another team.
Goddamn, they all went.
Oh, my God.
There was a third party instantly.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Not the ideal situation.
Are you awake now?
No, I wasn't used to playing Newcastle after playing six hours of Gibby.
You're right.
That was an intense switch up.
And I was just like, Q.
I was like, alright, here's the Q.
And I was like, oh, wait, I have a fucking actual wall.
Oh, my God.
Well, this is another just chatting session between you and all of us here.
It's okay.
It's just first game never doesn't matter, guys.
It's just first game.
Yeah, now we're gonna be focused after this one.
Now I can actually fix my stream.
Yes, fix it up, please.
But hey, we survived the winning bracket for such a long time.
I guess in the losing bracket we still have a chance, like a great amount of chance, I think.
We literally just need three good games and then we make it through.
Oh, my God.
We just need three good games.
Immediately we fumbled the first one.
Yeah, I mean, that's what happened last time.
That's what happened yesterday.
We just fumbled the first game.
It's fine.
I'm waking up.
I mean, we fumbled, like, the first thing yesterday, too, right?
When we started the tournament.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna give them false hope that they think they're gonna win.
No, we're gonna win here.
We are the wrong characters.
Yeah, that was unfortunate.
And then I didn't know which way to loot because I was like, okay, this is a new drop spy.
Where the fuck do we go here?
I mean, to be fair, we were kind of late, so it is our fault.
Exactly.
We're gonna make it even more epic by holding up for this mistake.
Everything was against us from the very start.
So it's fine.
Life had to nerf us.
Exactly.
We were just playing too good.
As the only full foreign team, like, everything was already against us.
The ping is against us, the POI, everything.
The characters, too.
I'm very surprised you get 300 ping.
I know!
I thought I was gonna have, like, really great ping because I'm really close to Japan.
Yeah, exactly, because I was like, man, I cannot.
I'm in PH, stuff like that.
Like, it's really close.
Yes, that's why I'm like, how do you get 300 ping?
Yeah, I don't know why.
It's probably a routing issue.
Yeah, it's probably a routing issue.
I've never had this thing in, like, whenever I'm playing with the boys.
It's just like, for some reason this has, like, high ping.
I don't know.
Question mark.
You might as well be in fucking NA at this point.
I have the same ping issues as you guys.
I was just like, oh my gosh, at least it's only me that's far away from...
I was like, it's only me that's far away.
And I'm like, wait, you guys all have 300 ping?
For real, though, even with ping issues, even with that, we're still cracking.
It's fine.
It's good.
It's alright.
Where are you from, Doki?
NA.
Canada.
Oh, okay.
Why do you think I was like, I'm sleepy.
What time is it at your place of flame?
It is 644 PM.
I'm 744 right here.
I'm 344 AM right now.
I'm fucking, woo, 344!
No!
Let's go!
Wait, what time was it when you were like, uh, yesterday?
What time was it?
Oh, no, that was fine.
It was midnight.
It was 12 AM.
Oh, that was, okay, that was fine.
That was fine.
It was midnight.
I don't know.
Midnight is fine.
I'm still awake at midnight.
So, like, when it's midnight, I don't take a nap, because I was like, it's fine.
It's like, midnight can stay up for that.
But then, like, you know, I was like, alright, the match is starting at 330, so I should take a nap.
I should take a nap then.
And I was like, let's go.
I'm waking up at 320.
For some reason, though, like, um, whenever it's like 3 AM or 4 AM, I can stay awake from 1 to 2 AM, but once it hits like 3 or 4, I suddenly feel sleepy.
Like, out of nowhere.
12 to 3?
I get really tired if I stay up.
So, I was just like, I also have, like, a convention to do at 930.
So, like, I was like, Alright, after this game, I don't know if I could, I think I could take a nap before the convention.
Oh, what event is that?
It's Halloween Matsuri.
So, like, yeah.
And then I have a meet and greet at 930.
And then I have a panel at 1230.
Hey, just so you guys know, if you want to go there, go there now.
I'm waking up.
I'm heading there at 930 AM.
You guys better be there too.
Yeah, shout out to that one.
You gonna sleep through that?
Or are you just...
Post Apex?
Yeah, post Apex.
I was like, alright, I'm ready.
No, I'm trying to take a... I don't know.
Usually it's three hours, so, like, I most likely get to have, like...
We end at 630.
I'll have, like, a three hour nap, maybe.
Dude, I need you to, like, chug in, like, um, I don't know if you're drinking coffee, but I need you to drink that, like, immediately after this.
Yeah, I'll get some Gamersofts on.
Guys, I have a Gamersofts code, DokiBird.
It's, like, 10% off.
Like, use the code DokiBird.
10 % off.
Use the code of Doki in the link in the description below.
I'm not sponsored, though, but she is.
So, uh, go check that out.
Yeah, totally.
Check me out over there.
10% off on Gamersofts, guys.
Works.
I've never actually had, like, um, like, drinks like those.
How tasty is it?
It's actually really good.
It's really good.
Even though I am sponsored by them.
Is it like, um, energy drinks?
Like, um, Gatorade?
Stuff like that?
Yeah, it's like powdered energy drink, basically.
You mix it yourself.
I've never had that.
Just, like, straight-up bottle thing.
Yeah, yeah.
You just, like, mix the powder up with water, and then you fucking chug.
Not chug it, but, like, you know, just drink it.
And it actually works.
Like, the best thing about being sponsored by them is that they always send you free samples, like, all the time.
That's nice!
So I literally never have to buy anything.
So I could just, like, use it.
Dude, the only energy thing that I have here that's in powdered form is, like, milk.
I have powdered milk on me.
Oh, no, that's an energy drink.
That's not even... yeah, I was gonna say powdered milk.
Yeah, it's powdered milk!
It's like, uh, this is yummy.
I don't know.
For me, though, it keeps me, like, from getting hungry.
It's not actually an energy drink, but...
Yeah, it keeps me from getting hungry.
Like, I mix it in with water, and, like, I just drink it.
Yeah, and then I don't feel hungry anymore.
Because I... usually I stream for longer hours, so I decide to, like, invest in, like, this powdered milk, because, uh, you know, it tastes great, you know, so, uh...
Yeah.
Sorry, guys!
I'm a milk enjoyer!
I do not drink anything else but water and milk.
They are really great.
Really great.
Not sponsored, though, by the milk.
Not sponsored by milk, by the way.
Not sponsored.
Not sponsored by milk, but it's great.
You need to drink milk.
Not sponsored by cows.
Milk is good for you.
Whoever invented cows, yeah, not sponsored by that one.
The company that made cows.
Thank you, Domestication for domesticating cows.
Shoutout to you guys.
Thank you, farms.
Thank you.
Thank you, farmers for doing that.
You're doing an awesome job.
Keeping me alive.
GerardTRexpert.
Domestication, milk was, like, actually undrinkable.
Whoa!
Really?
Yeah.
How undrinkable is it?
Like, you would die or something?
I think, like, there was just so much bacteria from the...
I mean, I could be actively lying to you right now, but I'm spreading misinformation.
I mean...
I mean, things have changed in the past, so, you know...
I could honestly just be lying.
Let's check that out right now, then.
Because it sounds possible.
It's honestly believable.
Like, what you're saying right now is honestly believable.
Like, cows nowadays are probably injected with, like, a bunch of, um...
like, medicine or something?
Yeah, to make it... Well, technically, you're not supposed to drink cow milk, like, off the fucking teats anymore, because, like, you have to, like, actually, like, do stuff to the cows.
Oh, yeah.
Boil them, I think.
Like, because I remember, like, technically with all the fucking medication we give cows and stuff, we're not supposed to just drink the cow's milk raw.
We have to actually do stuff to the milk before we can...
Yeah...
Dude, cartoons made me think, like, sucking it out of, like, a cow's teats or something...
will actually work.
Yeah, if you think about it, you're technically sucking milk off the cow boobs, so, like, that's fucked up, Jared.
I mean... I mean, cats do it all the time, so why can't we do it, you know?
I was just like, okay.
You mean, like, every other mammal?
Like, why specifically cats?
Like, every... I mean, because I watched, like, every mammal...
We do that.
Humans do that.
Yeah, you guys, you know what...
Is it a Disney movie where, like, I saw this one specific thing.
I forgot what it was.
I think it was Charlotte's Web or something.
Yeah.
I don't know if it was that, but the cats were, like, drinking milk straight from, um, cows or something.
I don't know.
Oh, weird time.
What?
Straight up from a cow?
Yeah, like, uh...
Hey, they were drinking it, like, immediately from... Not straight from a cow, but, you know, from a bucket.
Like, they squeezed it and, like, they were drinking it.
It looked so tasty.
They were just having a fill.
I'll just shut up.
You are digging a deeper hole for yourself right now, Jared.
It's hard to explain!
But when I was a kid, they were having a fun time drinking that milk straight from the bucket.
Like, man, I'm craving for some milk right now because they were like, mm-mm, yummers.
Yummers.
Okay, so your dream right now is to drink cow milk from a cow?
That's not my dream.
I'm just saying, when I was a kid, they made it so delicious that I thought it was possible to drink it straight from the teat without any processes at all.
Shut the fuck up.
You're half asleep.
You don't know what you're talking about.
Whoa!
No, I definitely know what I'm talking about.
No, you don't.
Now I'm definitely awake after learning about you.
I think you should take a nap for a bit.
That's, like, a secret that you share.
I think you're still sleepy.
That's a secret you share to somebody after, like, knowing them for, like, ten years.
Not, like, right now in the Apex tournament.
In a way, this is what you call, like, a trauma- not a trauma bond.
We're bonding in a moment.
We're building chemistry.
Chemistry!
I'm learning something so intimate.
What?
This team won the fight?
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
Okay.
I didn't expect- The team we died to has just gone second place.
Yeah!
I didn't expect this team to win that- to get second place.
That was not- that team should not have lived for second place.
Like, that was so stupid from the other team to let that happen.
He managed to run away, play behind a wall, and the other team just killed him.
That's crazy.
Whoa.
Well, that was the first game, everybody.
We already have the winner.
So, it's... yay.
Oh, yeah.
Pasteurization.
Yeah, that's what I was talking- Oh, I was right.
I wasn't spreading misinformation.
Whoa.
See, it is believable.
Pasteurization.
Let's go.
I got, like, 90% of my information correct.
That's not fair.
Did you get that from school or did you get that from YouTube?
I don't know.
Honestly, I might have just got it from Twitter.
I get most of my news on Twitter anyway.
No, I just- If it's important enough to show up on my Twitter feed, that's good enough for me.
Dude, I get mine from Zachty Films or something.
Like, 3D animated reels and Instagram or something.
My 4U algorithm is so fucked up right now.
It's like Marvel Rivals and then- Yeah, I was about to say.
It's literally just that.
It's Marvel Rivals and then stuff about me and then news.
That's so random.
It's just something suddenly just news.
I thought it would be, like, fucking brain rot.
Or, yeah, it's like news and memes.
That's basically it.
That's like- Oh, my God.
Yeah, mine's like 90% memes most of the time.
Game 2!
Let's go!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we gotta lock in.
For real.
Exactly.
We weren't last.
Despite everything going against us.
We were 19th place, but it's fine.
Don't worry.
We were one fight away from, like...
One sec.
One fight away from what?
From how many points the team that killed us got.
We're- We're how many points?
We're one fight away from coming second place.
Oh, my God.
Let's fucking go.
Woo!
I'm so awake.
So, what does that mean?
Did we do good?
Unfortunately, still no.
I thought there was hope over there.
I thought it was a chance.
Yeah, you could have lied to us and we'll accept it.
I mean, all we have to do now is just keep on believing again.
Yeah.
I agree.
As long as we believe, the chance is always there.
As long as we pick the right characters and also, like...
Okay, okay.
I understand.
No, I wasn't finished.
I wasn't...
Okay, go ahead.
Finish.
As long as we pick the right characters and, like, we know how to rotate, things will be great.
Things will be fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
Okay, all right.
Woo!
Same place?
Same place we're dropping?
Yep.
All right.
Okay, we're...
Okay, lock in characters.
No, no, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do you mean, no?
What?
Sorry, sorry.
We're suddenly switching things up?
Listen, I'm also a little bit...
Okay.
You're not the one who fell asleep!
You're not the one that's...
It's 6pm!
For you!
Listen, listen.
I've got no excuses for myself.
Yeah, okay, that's good.
At least you take accountability.
Great, great, great.
We like that about you.
Okay, all right, all right.
I'm so ready.
All right.
Woo!
Okay, now that I know how to loot this place, it should be okay.
Mm-hmm.
Hopefully the zone doesn't pull on us so we can go scan at cascades.
Yeah, hopefully.
Would be nice.
Don't worry, I'm awake now.
For real.
You definitely sound awake.
I believe you.
Thank God.
Enemy was a misspelling.
Whoops.
I'll pick this carbine for now and just see if there's a carbine in this area.
I got an R-301 here if you guys want.
Yeah, I do need that, but I need to loot this first.
There's a scout here.
Okay, yeah, we're scanning over at cascades.
Do you want that scout or no?
No, I'm okay.
I need a...
I'm gonna stay on nemesis, actually.
There's a blue backpack here.
I'm gonna grab the cache and then also grab the carbine.
Alright.
Did you finish looting your area, Jeroid?
I...
Shit.
Let me know if I missed anything because I couldn't see any cells.
Whoa, okay.
I was looking!
I was like going back and forth!
I'm looking!
I didn't know what you just said to me.
I'm trying!
I'm trying to find cells!
Whoa.
Is that right?
You don't have much loot there, Jeroid.
Your place is kind of...
Okay, this place is more about rotation.
I know lion's land's here.
Yippee.
Vroom vroom.
Stop here for a second.
I got it.
Let's go again.
I'm here.
We got the cascades here.
Yippee.
Let's hope we don't get shot.
That would be so funny.
Just get ready to bubble the car.
You have to look into the car and then bubble.
Okay, whoops, sorry.
Just hit console here.
Jeroid, come, come, come.
Hit the console.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Holding.
Okay, got it.
In the car, beep, beep.
Just look into the car and then bubble.
Yeah.
What's the cooldown at?
7 seconds.
Should I test it?
I've never done it before.
It should be okay.
I'm worried I might fuck that up.
Doors are open.
Give me one second.
No, no, no, don't leave.
Come back.
Do it now.
Yeah, I did it.
Okay, all right, inside.
We're getting off here.
We're just taking this house.
Come, second floor.
Okay, second floor, second floor.
Okay, there's a team on the other house.
We just have to drill here.
Just put walls up.
Put walls on this door too.
And then put a wall here.
This door below us.
If you can.
I'll come with you so you don't get ran at.
All right.
Put it more against the door.
It's not against the door.
Can you come up to me?
Okay, so press Z.
Hold right click.
Aim here.
At this wall.
Oh, wow.
That guy has destroyed me.
Okay, I'm going to replace the wall.
Yeah, just replace the wall.
I need you to break the door with your shield.
Just do it really quick.
Peek.
You don't want to shoot your cover.
You want to uncrouch.
Break the door and then come back.
Okay, that's fine.
Should we wall the stairs?
Or do you want us to wall the doors?
All the doors downstairs.
Uh, yeah, just wall all the doors.
Okay, Dread, come here.
Don't mind walling that yet.
Just wall this door with me.
I'll play with you.
Just wall this.
And then wall this door.
Oh, look here.
Oh my god, okay.
All right, that should be fine now.
We'll be able to...
We'll be fine then now.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, you might have to re-wall this.
But don't get hit.
They're bubbled.
Careful.
On the second floor.
I'm four shield cells.
Okay, I'm replacing the shield.
Uh, you can...
Yeah, you have to do that.
He's just getting like...
There's nothing we can do.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't know there was a team already.
All right, I'm three now.
I'll just wait.
I'm waiting.
I'm just not peeking.
Uh, what's your heals?
Okay, I'm gonna replace it.
Okay, I'm two, seven.
I'm giving you...
Two cells.
I'm not gonna peek though.
What's your heals, Gerard?
I got, um...
Two syringes and...
Six, um, batteries.
Six batteries?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
Give me two cells, Gerard.
I'll give you a bat.
Thank you.
Just be careful peeking that.
Be really careful peeking that.
Oh, they destroyed this door too.
Um...
I guess I'll just stay here.
I hear people to my left.
Can you break this door, Gerard?
With your ulti.
Okay, Sheila?
Yeah, just break this door here.
I hear footsteps to my left, but I don't know how close they are.
Nice, cool.
It'd be nice to peek.
It'd be nice to not be shot by two different teams.
Oh, they're shooting.
Yeah, it's okay.
That's fine.
As long as they don't see me, everything will be fine.
They don't know I'm right here.
I think what we have to be most careful of is a team from northwest, guys.
From this house here on my red ping.
Sliding down our bottom door.
Like, our bottom doors.
We have walls right on those doors though, so...
Yeah, but...
They can just bubble and then...
Climb over the walls.
Should I replace this one?
No, I think...
Delete that.
Press X on it.
Do you have to...
Should I come back down to you guys?
Careful with this window, Gerard.
They have a rampart cover on the other side.
Yeah, he's looking.
He's literally looking.
No, you can stay there.
It's okay.
Alright.
Just take this cover away, Gerard.
I can't...
How do I... Can't remote pick up damaged wall.
Ah, I see.
Okay, you just... You have to slide into it.
And then just press X on it.
And then you come back.
Nice.
When you go over this window, Gerard...
You wanna hit a slide jump.
No, no, no.
Take it out.
Take it away.
Just get rid of that.
Yeah, it's okay.
Just come to me now.
You don't have to put the wall down.
Just run back.
Slide jump to me.
Nice.
I think you should put the wall down right here, Gerard.
Yeah, that's perfect.
I feel so safe, guys.
You can replace this wall again.
You know what?
If the zone pulls away, there's a good chance we're gonna car and bubble out.
Alright, cool.
Yeah, not last!
Let's go!
That's not us, guys.
That's not us!
There's a team that landed out here, Doki.
Uh-oh, okay.
Okay, where you looking at?
Yeah.
Oh, I might die.
Get inside, get inside.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
You want me to come over to you guys or stay here?
You can stay.
I hear footsteps next to us.
Where?
Like this side, but I don't know if they're close by.
I just heard footsteps right next to me.
I'm gonna turn up my poking gun.
I don't see anything.
They're shooting over this direction.
They're fighting over here.
Yeah.
Oh, that's close.
That's close.
They're right here.
They're getting bullied really hard.
Yeah, fuck you guys.
I think instead of putting the cover here, Gerard, maybe put the cover up on me.
So get rid of this one and then come up to me.
Be really careful coming up because you can die to this really easily.
Just try and run to me right away.
Nice.
Put the wall, I think, just right here.
People are so serious right now.
This lobby is so serious.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
All my homies hate Stormpoint.
Oh.
I hear him.
He might be close.
I think he's underneath.
Yeah, I think so too.
I'm just peeking.
I think he walked out this door.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, we're still in zone.
Oh, this is scary.
No!
Team, push us, okay?
Be really careful.
I'm just gonna full heal then.
I'm full healing.
Just in case.
Just don't...
Just in case we get pushed.
Oh, I hear.
If we get pushed, we just play towards the stairs, okay Doki?
You're probably gonna bubble stairs and then we might look to make a push.
We just side jump into them.
Uh...
Yeah.
Should I stay here to get ready or no?
Hmm...
Come over now.
Yeah, I think you just come play stairs.
I think if we get pushed, it's likely not gonna be from your side.
We have no covers.
Can you place a cover up here on me, Droid?
Like on my red ping here?
Be careful placing it.
We need presence.
Yeah, that's fine.
Just leave it.
We have one more cover you can place.
Just place it back...
No.
Yeah, you can.
Come, Droid.
Place a cover right here, Droid.
Actually?
Take this out, Droid.
Come outside to me, Droid.
Oh, shit.
Where do I put it?
Put it on me.
Be really careful.
Come to me.
Put it right here.
Right here?
You can go back inside.
Be really careful.
Do you see that window, Droid?
If you run like that and they're looking through that window, you will die.
Oh, God.
Okay.
If you die in the game, you die in real life, so don't let that happen.
Alright.
At least not last place.
If we survive two more placements, we get one point, Droid.
Alright, let's go.
Yay!
We just need two more teams to die.
Wait, is that true?
Fifteen places when we get one point, right?
Yeah.
We need one more team to die, so...
Come on, guys.
If we get one point...
There's a care package out here.
This team might go first.
We can bubble car and take it.
I don't know.
That's still really risky.
Team car in here.
Look at this.
Coming to us.
They have red armor.
They landed right under us.
You have to look at this.
I'll come up.
You maybe wanna...
Gibby ult this.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Gibby ult this?
I'm gonna try peeking this, okay?
You guys stay.
I'll stay in the stairs.
I'm staying in the stairs.
I hit... I didn't hit shields yet.
I just hit shields.
Oh shit, we're inside.
We're in a really good spot.
I broke the rampart wall.
Let's go.
Fourteen.
This team might try and push us, guys.
This team is our biggest threat here.
I broke the rampart wall.
Can you...
Can you come up to me, Gerard?
Okay, I'll stay then.
I need you to place a rampart cover like...
Facing this way.
Okay, alright.
Come crouch exactly on me, Gerard.
Come to me.
Don't crouch.
Just come to me.
Okay, coming.
Don't crouch.
Come exactly to me.
Oh, this...
We have to...
We have to make sure they don't walk at us here, guys.
Okay, this door...
This wall is gone.
So just stay...
Don't put... You don't have enough walls.
So don't put...
Don't stand there because they can shoot you here.
Just stand here.
Be careful!
I don't really know what we can do about this.
We just gotta fight, I guess.
We get pushed.
I can bubble then.
We can cohabitate and just...
No, I think we don't fight.
We just cohabitate and play second floor.
The problem is they have...
Red armor.
All three of them.
I'm looking upstairs just in case.
One point, guys!
One point!
I'm flying in from west.
I hear... I hear team to my left.
Team to my north.
That flew in.
They landed behind this house.
Okay, listen.
There's only one team on this west side.
Literally the red armor team.
Yeah.
We need to find another place to go.
Oh, shit!
There's a team here.
We have to wait a bit.
I'm looking down the stairs just in case.
Just be careful of people pushing us.
I'm just gonna sit against the door for now.
Shit, it's right behind us.
I'm sitting against the door for now.
Try just...
Sit in the stairs.
I'm risking my life sitting against the door.
Someone's sliding over.
Okay, no.
I don't hear them.
We need to...
Find a spot.
Well, the fact that no team has died from this small ass circle...
I think we're moving now, guys.
Can you come to me?
Okay, yeah.
Run with me.
Just come to me.
Run, run.
Come with me.
Oh, there's a team here.
I think we just killed them.
Ready?
Wait, wait, wait.
Two seconds.
I'm nading.
Ready?
Peek this.
Peek this now.
Peek him.
Push, push, push.
Flash.
Two, two, two.
Last guy.
Flash.
Got him, got him, got him.
Nice.
There's a creeper, creeper, creeper.
Rampart, rampart, rampart.
There's two creepers, two creepers.
Okay, okay.
You take one.
I take the other.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm queuing us.
We're okay.
Just relax.
Relax.
That's fine.
It was one creeper.
JK.
Okay.
It was two.
Wait, what happened to the boxes?
We need to hold this side, guys.
We need to hold this side.
Okay.
They landed on him.
I'm looking.
We just have to look at this.
I cracked one.
Nice, nice.
Just keep looking at that.
The bubble ends soon.
It's ending now.
They're on us.
Look at this.
Okay, hold on.
I'm bubbling.
Just chill.
There's nades here.
Can we peek them now?
Peek them now.
They're fighting.
I got one.
Peek this.
I'm pushing up with you.
Bottom left.
On me.
Push.
Pull down.
Go back.
We stay in our spot.
We have a really good spot.
We want to go back here.
I'm back in.
Careful.
I'm getting massive now.
Dude.
Everyone only has an R3.
We can't let people peek above us.
Above us is our biggest threat.
I'm looking above.
I'm against the wall.
There's a team across us, I think.
We just...
Zone literally ends on us.
There's a team on our bottom here.
There's a team on our bottom.
You need to put rampart covers on me, Gerard.
They're looking to fight us.
I'm looking.
They're pushing.
Just hold.
Hold on the walls.
I have to do this.
I'm healing through this.
Just hold.
Give me ult.
This is my ult, but I'm not getting hit by it.
I'm gonna get hit by it.
I'm gonna get hit by my ult.
It's okay.
We need to kill them here.
I hit two cracks.
Let's go.
Just push.
They're going.
Knocked one.
Just keep me.
You can rez me, Doki.
I can't see you.
Just kill him first.
Nice.
Down.
I know.
Block.
Use your shield.
Left click.
We need to go right.
I know.
I'm syringing it.
It's fine.
Come to me.
I'm with you.
No.
12 seconds.
They're looking at us.
We're dead.
Hold shield.
Keep walking forward.
I'll hold shield for you.
I'm holding shield.
I had to use bubble.
My bad on the comms there.
I meant the rez after you kill him.
I should've been more clear on that.
We got third.
We got third place.
We got a lot of kills for that too.
Nice.
Great job.
We should be safe.
My chat was like...
His IGL tone is so good.
You have a fan.
You have a fan in my chat.
Subscribe to him and follow him on Twitch.
We got nine kills off of that.
That's good.
We got nine kills.
Nice.
Great job.
How many points did that get us?
I don't know.
How many points did we get from that?
We got 16.
That's really good.
We just need one game.
Just one game, please.
Yeah, we just need one game.
One game, please.
We should be okay.
I'm going to use the bathroom and I'll be right back.
I didn't even wake up.
I went straight to my PC.
I didn't want to fucking do anything else.
I can feel the adrenaline.
I can feel the high.
This is it.
I think I'm going to go through my addiction today.
What the fuck?
Literally after yesterday's stream, I was still playing.
I immediately called my friend.
We should go rank.
Let's go rank.
Let's test this thing out.
Oh my god, that was so fucking intense.
I could feel it.
This is it.
I could feel the dub today.
I don't know when, but I could feel it.
It's right here.
Not jinxing it, but it's right here.
God damn.
Third place?
How many more do we need?
Top fives?
Top fives or what?
How good are we talking about?
One more of a game like that.
If we get top five, we'll probably need two.
If we get top three, we'll probably only need one.
But it depends on the kills we get as well.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Getting top three gives you seven points.
Getting nine kills gives you nine points.
One kill is one point.
Just depends.
Alright.
I'm back.
I'm so awake right now.
I say as I lie.
Look at that heart pumping.
Look at my stream on Discord.
Your stream on Discord?
What are you doing?
Is the team that we killed on the rock?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to see.
I was throwing godnades on them.
Yeah!
Whoa!
That was insane.
That was an insane lane.
Because when I got in, I was like, whoa, they're all dead.
They're all like one HP.
I was like, whoa.
Dude, that was insane.
Holy crap.
You just gotta do that ALGS then.
Yeah.
I think so.
I was hitting headshots on people that were like with no HP.
Yeah, that's crazy.
He's literally one HP there.
Holy fuck.
And then I headshot another guy that's flashed.
What the heck?
Thank god you got the Kraber.
The Kraber wouldn't have helped.
I was hitting people one HP for 200.
What is that for?
We clean it up.
But if I had another gun, I would have still done that same damage.
But it won't be as cool.
No, it won't be as cool though.
Too bad it only dried and I can see it.
Guys, it was really cool, guys.
You should have been there.
I promise it was cool.
It was really, really cool.
Yeah, post it.
I'll comment on it.
We'll like and retweet it.
This is how awesome Flame is.
I don't want to post that.
I'm down to post the vote review from yesterday.
Vote review!
Just immediately silent.
Wow, I just hyped you up and you do this to me.
I'm not going to lie, it is embarrassing to have that, but it was actually helpful.
It was a good Iowa Wizard.
It was good.
It hurts, but it's good.
That was so fucking embarrassing, but okay, you know what?
I get it.
We all start from somewhere, Drew.
When I first started, I was horrible.
See?
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for reassuring me that we all start from somewhere.
My first season playing this game, I had a 0.6 KD.
Whoa!
I'm not alone in my adventure.
Like, look, listen.
By the next time we team up, or if ever that happens in the future, like, for real, I am going to be way better.
No!
I won't be teaming up with him.
I'm going to be facing against him.
Whoa!
Oh, that's a challenge right there!
Oh no, that sucks.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's really hard to play the game like this.
Yeah.
Just keep an eye out on teams rotating around us.
Northpat does not know where Zone is going, but Checkpoint does, so if we see Checkpoint anywhere, we want to follow Checkpoint.
That's really hard, though.
Wall does not have console, so they don't know where it's going.
Cascades does console.
We want to look into these chokes here.
If someone comes from there, they likely know where Zone is going.
If someone comes from my yellow ping there, they likely know where Zone is going.
Nobody else does.
Alright, let's go!
See, your VOD review was so fresh in your head that you know where Zone is now.
I think that's just Northpat looking at us in the open.
Yeah, I see them looking.
I think our play is to go into Checkpoint and just hit the console.
I accidentally put shield.
Sorry.
I was trying to press tab.
We get shot at.
It's my bad.
It's fine.
It's the first few minutes.
Nothing can go wrong.
Yeah, we all want them to know we're here.
Yeah, just a bright blue moving shield.
I don't have shield for this.
We don't shoot them here.
We just let them go.
We're just hitting the console.
5 seconds.
I have it.
They're shooting at us.
Hit this.
Going.
Don't use bubble.
I did.
Sorry.
It was just instinct.
Get in the car.
Boom.
There we go.
We're going into Dump East here.
13 seconds.
Oh.
Okay.
I have 12 shield cells.
I have 3 bats, 12 shield cells.
Do you have bubble?
No.
Bubble car?
I got it.
Use it.
There's a demon there.
Oh, whoa.
They're shooting through.
Come to me.
This house is good.
Come here.
Come inside and just hold here.
I'm just closing the door.
We might get pushed from the left.
Careful.
Place your walls at all the doors.
Come here, Jordan.
We can grab this cash here.
Do you have bubble?
Yes, I do.
Don't close this door yet.
Okay.
There's another door.
Come here.
I'm against this door.
Put your wall here.
Okay.
We are in God's spot, guys.
Zone ends on us.
We have 2 more walls.
Where should we put it?
Put everything in this here.
Put one right here on this entrance.
Facing this way.
And then...
Put one probably...
This door is not fully closed.
You have to replace it.
You have to get rid of this.
Close the door and then place the wall afterwards.
Get rid of this door.
And now close the door.
Okay.
Come back.
We just have to fix the wall because we couldn't close the door.
And then come to me, Jordan.
Against the door.
Come to me, Jordan.
We are going to do this respawn thing.
Come up to me, Jordan.
Heal your armor.
How many heals do you have?
I have...
10.
Use 2 right now.
I'll look at the other door just to be sure.
Break this.
Actually, I'll just break it myself.
Sorry.
Drop your armor now.
Okay, dropping my armor.
Yeah.
Just right-click on the shield core.
At the bottom, you see your shield.
And then right-click to drop it.
Listen, so the plan is...
You're going to stand outside and die.
And then I'm going to respawn you.
And then we get evil points for doing that.
Just shoot at them if you can.
Where are they?
Your guns are really bad for shooting fire.
So you're probably just going to have to die.
Be careful with your ammo.
Should I drop some of them or not?
No, it's okay.
So when you get res'd, Gerard, we might get pushed.
And if we get pushed, I need you to take your armor right away.
That is the first thing you have to do.
Now, you can just walk out.
Die and take the armor here.
There they are.
You can walk out and start trying to die here.
No, Gerard, come back!
Gerard, no!
Come back!
Well, I'm dead.
No, you don't have to go up to them!
Bubble!
What the...
Oh my god!
I don't want Gerard!
Okay, just...
I don't think you should make him do this.
I'll do it.
I think...
I'll go up to Gerard.
No, I don't think it was worth that.
No, it's okay.
No, you just have to stand next to this door.
You don't have to go up to them, Gerard!
Oh my god, Gerard!
Oh my god!
Drop your armor again, Gerard.
You need to die.
You need to die on these doors.
You need to die on these doors, Gerard.
Okay, on these doors.
Come back again.
I don't need to die over here.
I don't need to charge at them!
Oh my god!
You are playing on my heart, Gerard.
You said die, and I was okay.
I'm gonna go right in.
Oh my god!
What is that?
It's time!
You can just keep the door open, Gerard.
Just keep the door open.
You don't have time.
Okay, come at me!
You guys have scopes, by the way.
I do, I do, I do.
Can I borrow yours?
Holy crap!
Just keep...
Doki, look at the other way for now, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, I am, I am.
I'm looking at...
Hey, hey, hey!
Guys, I'm over here!
Someone's running!
Hey, hey, hey!
Oh, another hit!
Hey, hey, get over here!
Don't waste too much of your ammo, Gerard.
How much do you have?
110.
Don't shoot, don't shoot, don't shoot.
Just stay there, just show yourself.
I'm waiting for my chat to...
I'm jumping, I'm jumping.
I'm right here, I'm right here.
I'm waiting to see my chat's reaction to what we just experienced.
They better...
Someone clip that shit, please.
Oh no, from my POV, it was so bad.
It was so bad.
When I see, like...
When I see...
Okay, I'm down, I'm down.
Oh my god, that was so bad.
That was so bad.
Okay, there.
Got it, got it, got it.
Okay.
Do you want me to do it again?
Do it, Gerard, do it.
You can drop your armor again, and then do that again.
Okay, I'm gonna die again?
Yeah, yeah.
Drop your armor again, drop your armor again.
Gerard, place a cover, like, on me.
Right on me.
Come to where I'm sitting.
Yep, and then face this way, and then just place it that way.
Yeah, perfect, perfect.
Come and do that again, Gerard.
Okay, gotta do it again.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Right here, right here, right here.
Right here, right here.
I'm literally right here.
Hey, hey, hey.
Oh my god, my VOD caught up!
Instructions uncleared!
Just stop moving, Gerard, just stop moving.
Okay, alright, alright.
But come a little bit closer again.
Yeah, you don't want to stay too far for him.
Okay, I'm right here, right?
Yep, that's good.
Oh, here.
You just need one more hit.
Shoot it in my head!
There, here.
I think now I know why dinosaurs went extinct.
Because you told me to die!
We thought you understood the instructions very clearly, because I don't think you did!
I just want you to go outside and try to die!
Okay, easy enough.
Go back, Gerard, go back, go back.
Take your armor and then just heal, okay?
We can't die anymore, we can't die anymore.
Okay, alright.
We're still okay, but this team is not.
They might try and push us.
Doesn't he need to put a wall against the door, or no?
Uh, no.
Okay.
It's okay.
Someone's like, LGS is going to feel like a vacation after this.
Wait, Doki, can you stare at this for a bit?
Yeah, I can.
This team needs to move.
I don't know what their plan is, but we have to make sure they don't push us.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Oh, Gerard, careful!
I took bullets, don't worry.
Okay, okay, yes.
They're pushing up, the Valk pushed up a little.
Oh, there's a full team up here.
I'm okay.
They're flying away, they're flying away.
I'm looking at this.
There's a team to our left that also doesn't have a spot in the zone, guys.
Team to our left.
You see who's shooting right now?
That team doesn't have a spot.
Aren't they going to go up the... oh, they can.
Yeah, they are, they are.
They're going up.
Okay.
We want to play...
Yeah, we kind of want to play towards the outside here.
Okay.
I'm going to get the loot on these bins here.
And it just went running up the...
There's cells here.
Can you grab this, Doki?
Yeah, I can.
There's a team underneath as well, okay, be careful with that.
Yep.
Should I come with you or should I stay?
You can sort of stay.
Okay.
Are they flying over us?
Yeah, they're flying over there, I see them.
Is there...
Is my energy anywhere?
I don't think I saw energy.
How much energy do you have, Jordan?
I have energy?
Yeah.
Oh, energy ammo here, here, if you want it, take it.
Thank you.
Can you give me more?
How much do you have?
Here, take it.
I'm over here, Jordan.
We're out of zone here.
You didn't get in zone?
Yeah, just come left here.
We kind of want to play outside here.
Oh, God.
We want to play out towards the left.
There's a team in here we have to be really careful of.
In the building close, and there's a team above.
Should we start putting walls?
He's flying outside, Valkyrie.
No, I saw his flesh!
Sheila on the door.
That door is fake.
I think we just steal the team.
Use your Sheila.
On the door, only on the door.
Oh, he knocked someone!
Let's go!
I put bubble.
Push, push, push, push.
Keep me behind you guys.
Drive, please!
Come back, come back, come back to run.
Come back to run.
Oh, my God.
He stood in front of him!
We might get pushed from top-down beast, guys.
I thirsted him.
Good shit, good shit.
Oh, my God.
Wall this, we can't drive.
Look over me.
Look top-down beast for me.
Be careful looking at it, okay?
I need a full heal.
Give me a second.
Drive, look this way.
Look this way.
Okay, where do you want to look?
We need to walk in towards cannon, I think.
Okay.
We need to kill cannon.
They have shields.
I have zero attachments for my carbine.
Care the team top-down beast.
I'm grabbing nades.
Come up to me, come up to me.
Come up to me.
We're playing right on the left side of the cannon.
Go back, go back.
We're going car, we're going car.
Come back to me.
I need you to bubble the car.
Bubble car, bubble car.
I got the bubble, I got the bubble.
I'm still getting shot, though.
Just heal, just heal.
Set up, set up.
Set walls up.
Team above.
They might be gone already.
Just put walls around.
Just keep putting walls down, Jordan.
I got shot from here.
I don't know where they're at now.
I think the team above us went here.
I think the team above us is here.
I'm looking behind.
There's a team fight behind us right here.
Look at this, look at this.
I'm looking.
There's a team fight to my left.
There's a huge team fight here.
I can ult this.
I'm ulting.
They're dying here.
I got killed.
I ulted left side.
I'm okay.
We're getting looked at southwest.
We want to wrap this in here.
One team is full dead.
There's another team there.
Careful.
I have bubble.
They're fighting.
Can you come?
Alright.
Do you have Gibraltar ult?
No, I already used it.
Go back.
I had to use it for the first engagement.
It's okay.
Go back.
Careful.
They're going to try and fight us there.
They're going to try and fight us.
I'm covering.
You have to put rampart covers.
This team has to fight us.
They're going to Gibraltar bubble?
Yeah, I just bubbled.
Stay in the bubble if you can.
We have to just shoot this.
Gibby hit 80.
They're trying to fight us here.
Bubble faded.
Let them push.
They're peeking.
Oh, I got hit.
It's fine.
And B.
It was 3.
5 points.
We're okay.
Yeah, we got 5 points there.
Oh, they were so low.
That Gibby was 1.
Oh, they got quavered.
How many points was that?
I thought the bubble was going to last.
We got 5 points.
I thought the bubble was going to last longer than it did.
It just faded so fast.
I had the small bubble.
Yeah, I just got the small bubble.
Next time, I think you should take the longer bubble.
The longer bubble?
Okay.
Because we did small bubble yesterday.
Yeah, I think so.
We used to do small bubble when we played Bangalore.
You just get the bubble back so fast.
But when you have Newcastle, the longer bubble is better.
I only realized that after playing scrims with my teammates.
So do the right side then.
Yeah.
What was the other level up then?
Small bubble and longer bubble.
Oh, longer bubble?
Okay.
Well, it's now down to 5 squads.
We got 5 points from that.
So we just need another game.
And then we should be safe.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
So we're not at world's edge now.
So 22 points.
Are we at 22?
We should be if it's 5.
I think we're at 21.
21?
Okay.
21 points!
So we're going to need about 10 more points.
But it depends on the lobby.
Like, the winner's record we played, I think the cutoff ended up being around...
I think it was 36.
Was it 36?
Oh my god, I thought it was...
It depends.
It's like...
Yeah, I don't know.
It just depends how many points the teams above us are soaking.
But if everyone is like, Oh my god!
168 damage forever!
Did you see that?
Yes!
What the...
That's going to be me one day.
One day.
You see how fast he does his walls?
You have to have that type of reaction.
I need to get my game sense.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, decimating them!
They're on top!
That's going to be me!
Oh!
Look at him go!
That's going to be you!
Bro, that guy...
Holy shit, this team is insane.
Oh my...
That's going to be you!
Dude, that team...
Holy shit!
He clutched it!
Who the fuck?
Who is she?
That was insane!
Yo!
Insane!
You're going to be a new Rampart main right there.
I know!
It's actually kind of making me want to be a Rampart main.
Holy crap.
Those shields are just so useful.
Holy shit.
Next time, that's going to be me.
That's going to be you.
Right there.
Better strategy.
At least we're getting top 10s.
Continuously.
That's a good consistency over there.
Consistent, consistent.
Now we just need one more, right?
One more top 10.
I think we just need...
At least 10 points, right?
10 points, okay.
10 points should be okay, but...
We're going to need about 16 points if we want to be fully safe.
Okay, 16 points for fully safe.
That's...
No pressure.
None at all.
It's okay.
Definitely don't feel that pressure building up now.
It's fine.
We have...
There's a lot of team with 0 points, so like...
Jesus Christ, a 4th place team?
With...
That 4th place team with...
With 15 kills right there?
Jesus!
What the fuck was...
Oh, and there's a 14 points there too.
Goddamn.
Oh, it's Eden's team.
No fucking wonder.
15 and 14.
Damn.
Yeah, we have 21 points right now.
We're currently 7th place with 3 games.
No pressure.
We got this.
I'm so confident in this.
What did we get for World's Edge?
Wait, you never told us.
Geyser.
Oh, it's not that bad.
Yeah, yeah, where's World's Edge?
We're at your favorite place.
Where you got lost.
How did I have that one?
No!
I don't want to go underground anymore.
It would be so funny if that was the last.
It's our new home.
It's actually our new home.
It's too late.
This is where we live now.
Just underground.
No, no thank you.
As long as I stick with you, that would be fine.
Right?
Because I was very late before and I was very slow.
I can learn.
Oh, team 11 is Ditto's team.
I was looking at the wrong number.
That was the team that killed us, I think.
7 places the team that killed us.
They got 14 kills there.
Oh, we can do better.
Whoa, wait!
Flame had 0 kills?
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, what?
Someone in my chat was like, Jiraiya got 2 kills and Doki got 1.
And I looked at the match summary and I was like, overall, 3 kills.
The dream is coming true.
Watch out, Flame.
I'm going to get your ass.
Whoa, Flame.
Flame, Flame.
Unbelievable.
Flame, how many kills did you get in the last game?
I think you got like...
Well, last game I got 0.
The game before that, I think you had 7.
And I had 2.
Whoa!
No, you were cooking that game.
Goddamn nice.
Keep doing that, please.
From now on.
I need you to lock in again.
It's okay.
I mean, I feel like we did pretty well for the situation.
For real.
Am I going to light Jiraiya running all the way out?
Oh my god, that woke me up.
That actually woke me up.
That is a Twitter clip.
Just die.
You said die!
And my brain equated to just running down the slope.
I wish I knew what team we were fighting.
So I could know what the reaction is to this one guy just running at them with no shields.
I need to know what team we were fighting.
In another way, it seemed like we were taunting them.
From my perspective, I think it was a taunt.
What the fuck were they thinking of?
They're running out without a shield?
Jesus, out in the open?
Oh my god.
That was the most stupidest thing I've ever thought of.
How am I going to get revived?
Because I've never heard of that strategy before.
No, we were trying to do it yesterday!
We did it yesterday!
We did that?
Yes, we were trying to do that yesterday!
Because... oh shit, really?
I didn't notice!
God damn, I was okay.
Words were flying out of my ear apparently.
I did not remember that.
Maybe we need another VOD review.
Wait, wait, did I get it right?
Let me check my...
Wait, where should I land to loot?
I think someone needs to loot out here.
Okay, I'll go there then.
Out here, into this house.
Gerard, land on this here.
Land here, Gerard.
And then loot into the yellow ping there.
We just need to loot super fast and then rotate super fast.
Yep, yep, yep.
I have a redeploy.
Nice, that's good.
There's a rez here too.
Spitfire, oh god, triple take over here.
Yep.
I'm kind of feeling the lombo this game, I'm not going to lie.
Okay, I'll ping the triple take then.
I'll loot the right side.
Okay, I'm running triple take car.
Yep.
Actually, I'll do massive.
We need to go into monument here.
Okay.
You guys can just run up this way.
I have no scope, so...
I need to get that massive and then I...
Just go follow Flame.
Just follow Flame, you don't have to wait for me.
Just follow him.
I just need to grab this.
You guys can go up as well.
You want us to go from here?
Gerard, come here.
You go grab this blue bin.
Actually no, you just follow Flame.
I can go up then, because he's closer to you.
The blue bin's already been grabbed.
Someone's there.
You can still go, just be really careful.
We want this cache.
I'm heading over soon.
Just make sure there's no one on you.
I'll wait for you guys near the door and then I'll start going up.
Yep.
Alright.
Wait, was this looted, Flame?
No, I looted it.
Okay, I'm heading up now.
I have a 3x for someone, does anyone need this?
I need it, yeah.
Gerard has a 2x too, but I'll take the 3x actually.
Here, you want it?
No, it's fine, just move on.
You can start sliding down.
Nope, someone's in front of me here.
In the house.
I have an angle.
He was on this house, I don't know where he's gone.
I don't know who this is.
This could be from Overlook.
Right here, he's crossing right here.
Yep, I'm looking.
I think this is Overlook.
Where is he?
I'm taking the house.
I'm sliding down now.
We want to go into Monument here.
We want to hit this cache and go Monument.
I'm here.
Yeah, this is Monument.
This is Overlook coming, just go.
Alright, just follow Flame.
Follow Flame, Gerard.
Yep, yep, yep, following, following.
Following.
Need to get the zone.
Yeah, the person that hit that blue bin up top, Doki, I think was this guy.
Literally from Overlook, going all the way up here.
Crazy.
Got four cells and one battery from that house.
I have no bats.
I'm 2-11.
I can give you guys stuff.
I'm just 0-8 right now.
Okay, you don't need bats, Gerard.
I'll drop you bats later, Gerard.
Just keep going, guys.
If we can get this care package, that would be pretty nice.
We just run for this console here, and then I'll go grab care package.
Alright.
Whenever you can drop me a 3x, I can take it now.
I'm literally right behind you.
I'm kind of waiting for Gerard here.
Okay.
Oh, there's a 2x4, I don't need it, actually.
You don't need it, you can take it back.
Just go.
On the pack!
Come up here.
Going, going, going.
Zipping, zipping, zipping.
Okay, do the thing.
I bubbled.
Just scan it, Gerard.
They're also scanning people.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Come to me.
Jumping, jumping.
Oh, I hear people.
Huh?
That's me, I think.
Oh, okay.
Just keep coming to me.
Yep, yep, yep.
Cell, battery here.
I'll take it.
We want to go up to this house.
I'll give it to you.
We want to go up to that house, guys.
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
What's that going?
Oh, is someone there?
Someone's there, man.
We need to go left.
We need to walk up left here and go into the sky.
Follow my pathing.
I'm here, I'm here.
They have rampart covers.
Just run, just run, just run.
They're really far.
We have to be careful behind us.
You have to pop a battery right here, Gerard.
Just hold for three seconds.
Oh, you're in the open.
Okay.
We need to erase this up top.
In case they're walking at us.
I'm here.
I think we're okay.
Well, they were shooting at us, so they definitely know.
Just keep coming to me.
We have to walk behind my castle queue, okay?
You guys have to make sure.
I'm behind it.
I'm literally right next to you.
Okay, come.
Just keep coming, Gerard.
Get behind this queue.
Be careful.
We just go left now, we're okay.
A lot of shields though, so we need it.
Yep.
Okay, I have a plan.
It's gonna be pretty hard, but we need to play underneath skyhook here.
We could be getting redded on.
Coming, coming.
Oh, we're okay.
Alright.
Just keep coming.
If you see a sniper stalk, let me know.
Yep.
Oh, they're getting shot at too while they're scanning.
Just keep running forward to me.
We're gonna evac from behind this building.
Yep, come right to me.
Just keep coming.
Okay, can you throw the evac down?
Here?
Yep.
Oh, I hear peeps.
Yep, it's fine.
We're just going right away.
Right off, just click it.
Okay.
Fly with me here, we go right a bit.
We're landing in the corner left here on my run.
Yep, land right here on me.
Ow.
Bubble.
I can't, oh my god, it won't let me bubble.
It's fine, I rez him.
Just chill.
I'm gonna rip Newcastle with you here.
I think I got pinged there.
I pressed Q but it wouldn't bubble.
Oh man, that's...
Okay.
Just keep putting rampart walls on.
Another one down.
Put one close on our left here.
I can't, it's obstructed for some reason.
Okay, it's okay.
Just crouch here.
Crouching, popping a battery.
Yep, you can heal.
It won't let me.
What's your bubble on?
I have it now, I have it.
Okay, as soon as we get shot, you just have to use it.
There's a guy in the open here.
I think that's the team playing the...
Hey, look, rampart!
He's behind this car.
I don't see him.
Yeah.
He's gone.
Oh, they're shooting.
Just say drop a bubble and then I'll do the bubble.
Yep.
Hopefully they don't throw a nade.
Whoa.
We should be okay.
Okay.
At least not last place.
Whoa.
Spooky, scary.
Yeah, I mean, we're just gonna sit here like the whole game pretty much.
It's so spooky and scary.
This is where we live now.
This is our new home.
It's free real estate.
I'm making so much noise to make the team above us so paranoid.
Whoa.
This is literally where I'm gonna start my family.
Listen, Gerard.
I need you to put a wall down like this way to show presence.
It's gonna be really scary.
Outside?
Yeah, so come...
Yeah, I think you just throw a bubble that way.
Okay.
Okay, where do I...
Go, Gerard, go before the bubble goes.
Throw a wall down facing west, Gerard.
Yep, perfect.
Come back, come back now, come back now.
Okay.
We're so safe.
Oh, yo.
That is not good.
I have a lot of shield cells if you need it.
I have 15 cells.
Okay, nice.
I just wasted everything because I was getting shot everywhere.
Wait, how many cells do you have?
I have zero.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank you.
Careful of this, careful of this.
Yeah, I'm looking, I'm looking.
I have ulti.
I'm gonna save it for when we have to use your bubble.
Okay.
When you bubble, I'm gonna ulti as well.
Okay, just let me know when to bubble.
I have it now.
Yep.
Man, that's fucked.
Why would you destroy a house like that?
I know, right?
We're supposed to coexist.
Very uncivilized.
Yeah, we're here to coexist.
We're barbarians.
Oh, someone died to a ring.
I cannot believe what...
Why are you shooting it?
There was a guy in a window.
Oh, that guy, okay.
I shot like between his body and his arm.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
They got a mythic bin.
What?
That sounded so nice.
Oh, it's basically a red gun.
Oh, shit.
It is a red gun.
Someone shoot them, please.
Or damage.
Guys, I think we're moving.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Full team on me.
Come back.
Don't worry, we never moved.
We never moved.
He's like, never mind.
I'm like, oh, I'm still here.
I'm still here.
Have to be careful if this team has a crab area.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I have no idea what guns they have.
Yo.
Be careful.
That's okay.
He has so much shield cells right now that he can risk that.
I see nobody.
Like, I don't know how you're seeing people.
Oh, that's how...
I'm jumping for this.
You guys are scaring me.
Good luck.
It's fine.
Just stay there, Gerard.
You don't need to do anything.
Yeah, I'm just going to cradle myself here.
Because I don't even have a scope that could reach that far.
Wait, where's your 2x?
Right here.
I have it.
But I don't think it's going to be...
Oh, on my left.
Oh!
It's okay.
Just chill.
I'm covering.
Do you need white meds or are you good?
I'm okay.
I got 4 syringes.
He's fine.
He's so healthy.
Please stay healthy.
I'm looking at the left for you.
Yeah.
Still 18?
18 again?
How is he doing that?
Listen, we maybe make a play here.
Okay.
I was going to say, are you sure there's a lot of people around us?
Place a wall here again, Gerard.
We can start playing a little bit more aggro forward here.
Okay.
I'll stay here for now.
Anchor this a bit.
Okay, no.
We're still in a really, really good spot.
We just chill.
Yeah.
There's a spot somewhere here I think that's gonna be playable soon.
Okay.
I don't know what it looks like though.
We need to care for this team here.
This team does not have a spot in zone.
I'm looking northeast for us.
They're the only team we have to focus, guys.
Our second biggest threat...
Can you put a rampart wall down here?
Gerard?
Just right here.
Be careful.
Yep, just come back.
We just needed to show presence.
Okay.
This team has to move here.
Yeah, I'm looking for us too.
They don't have a spot to play.
This team is going to die.
This team has to walk up to us then.
Yeah, I don't think we'll be able to get any of the kills.
Yeah.
Well, let's hope.
No, we will!
We will!
Let's hope.
I have a peaking gun here.
I hear this.
17 seconds.
15 seconds.
People in this zone...
Nobody dies until the last ring.
Oh shit, really?
There's a lot of cover for people that just live in.
8 million buildings.
Yeah, that's why...
The end zone here is really scary.
If only real estate was this free.
IRL.
In this economy.
I'm looking right side.
They're not running right.
I think they're running left.
We're getting shot all the way left.
I don't know.
They definitely ran left.
I think they smoked it.
I think that's them.
Okay, our team just took the spot that I wanted to play.
I really want to kill this team above me.
There's no one to my...
Yeah, they all ran left.
I don't see anybody.
Guys, I think we should make a play.
We're going to triple run up to here right now.
Come with me.
Don't slide.
Walk.
Okay, nevermind.
We're not doing anything.
We're playing other side of this wall.
This is our house.
Yay!
This is where we live.
The circle is not anywhere near us.
It's all the way out west.
I think we should just take the risk.
Make the play.
Come.
Run.
I said...
Sit on me for two seconds.
We're going to run up the ramp here.
Ready?
One, two, three, come.
They're doing re-deploy from up here.
There's no one in here, I think.
Come.
Keep wrapping with me.
Do I just follow him?
Just follow him.
Don't mind me.
There's no one here.
Fighting under me.
Right here.
Keep me in the open.
Shooting.
Nice!
There's someone right below me.
Can we drop on them?
Nope.
There's a team.
Shoot this.
They don't have cover against us.
Flash!
Make the move soon.
One of them is flash.
Flash.
I have ult.
We need to fight this right now.
I'm right behind you.
Come with me.
They're fighting.
Come.
I'm bubbling.
Chill.
Just wait.
Got one.
Peeking now.
They have to fight.
Just chill.
Let them fight.
They're in the bubble.
I'm getting shot in the back.
Wait, that's you.
Bubble.
On me.
Fight.
He's one.
Sit on me.
No, I couldn't.
No, I trolled, man.
No.
Okay, so the ping was...
Wait, what was your ping then?
Went terribly over there.
No.
Some of the people were traveling and I was aiming randomly because it was clipping.
I mean, we got five points from that.
We got five pp.
We got seven points.
Yeah, that's good.
Good, good, good.
Another top ten.
Oh, that's 28 points.
We just need one more good game.
Man, I could've lived that there.
I had to heal.
I was so low.
I really needed to heal there.
You can't heal because it's outside of zone.
Yeah, I noticed.
I was outside of zone when I tried to heal and then I ran to you.
I didn't realize how fast the zone was against us.
More trust, Okie.
More trust.
Why do you think I'm telling you to come to me?
If I say jump, you say how high.
Goddamn.
Hey, I got two kills though.
I got two kills for that.
I got 45 damage.
But I did get my two kills.
I'm not gonna lie to you, Jahan.
At some point in that fight, I started running back and you just started shooting me.
Yeah, I shot...
I shot you once too.
You were like, there's a guy and I was like, wait.
I shot the first person I saw and it was you.
Because you like, got me and then I turned around and I just shot anything I see.
To be fair, I like, did no damage in the fight.
I don't know how I was missing.
But whatever.
That was rough.
Yeah, it was so rough.
Jesus Christ.
If we lived that, we would have been...
Dude, my pay is 269.
How is this... What?
I think you need it.
Okay, if we make it to the finals, we play tomorrow.
Oh, damn.
Again?
We play tomorrow and we make it to the finals.
But you're right.
I think you might need exit lag.
Oh, yeah.
I think you can get...
You can get one month free trial with exit lag.
I might actually need it for the tournament tomorrow.
Yeah.
I'm just thinking, imagine how much...
How well we do if you can actually shoot your gun.
I don't know.
I just didn't think I'd be getting this much worse like ping on the second day.
Yesterday was sort of okay, but god damn.
This was terrible.
Like, I didn't even know who I was shooting at.
Yeah, if you're like... If people are teleporting, that ain't good.
I know.
It's actually pretty bad.
Fine, I might have to like subscribe like literally after this tournament.
God.
If we make it to the finals.
If we make it, which we are.
Did you see what he did?
Dude, just literally shot him straight in the face.
No, the downed guy blocked the other guy from climbing over the wall.
That's crazy.
He literally body blocked him from climbing the wall.
Dude, I thought it was like a Mufasa kind of thing.
He was just looking at him in my point of view.
Damn.
Okay, at least it was another top 10.
Great.
Great job, everybody.
So far we're not like straying from the consistency.
Yeah, we're very consistent today.
That's good.
We're very consistent.
But we're getting further and further away from the top 10.
Literally at the second round we were like third.
Now we're like how much?
How far were we?
We're eighth.
Last game we were eighth too.
Oh my god, please, please.
We need to at least another top 10.
Yeah, we just need another decent game and we should be locked in.
I don't even know what the cutoff is right now.
To be fair.
I have no idea what the cutoff is.
They haven't posted it.
Oh, I'll wait the...
Oh wait, we have the scoreboard.
It's already updated, yeah.
We're at 28 points.
Cutoff is at 24.
There's two more games.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Cutoff is going to be high 30 again here.
Unless someone chokes.
So we're at 28.
We'll see.
We need like 12 more points here in the next two games.
We're one good game and we're okay.
12, that's...
Oh wait, we're at 28.
Nevermind, we don't need 12.
I'm stupid.
Yeah, I was going to say 12.
I thought we were so close to 30.
We need 8 to 10.
Alright.
We should be okay.
Flame says die.
Gerard asks how many times.
If it means winning, yes.
You Jetters are brutal.
They're always brutal against me.
For some reason.
So Gerard got the opposite of trust issue.
I fully trust whatever this Flame gives to me.
I will do it for this team.
Oh my god.
Right there, if we chilled a little bit and let the two teams fight, I think they would have won.
I saw them and I was like How did you just pre-shoot?
The pressure was on us, really.
We couldn't really think.
I just wanted to get those kills too.
I called to push at the start because I didn't see anyone.
Turns out there was a full team ratting in the corner with the Rampart.
We would never know.
There were just three men sitting in the corner.
For me, I was just like I could get all these kill points.
They're not looking at us.
I was like That's so juicy.
Right there.
Game start soon.
We got this.
Okay, thank god.
Well, at least I'm not getting kicked out.
You didn't get kicked out from the lobby.
Yeah, and we're not restarting and resetting the map every single time.
Yeah, today's a good day.
The only bad thing that happened today is that Everything is way worse.
It's not even better.
I'd rather get disconnected than fucking missing every shot or like just shooting at the flame.
At least you didn't.
We don't have to restart the game.
You're right.
At least we don't have to restart the game.
It's the little things in life.
Yeah.
Enjoy those things.
Are we really going to ignore the first thing that happened?
Yes.
The first game.
We were not human on the first game.
We were not real people there.
Yeah, we were just warming up.
We were so scuffed.
I wasn't a real person at that time.
Yeah, specifically you only.
You just literally woke up from your slumber.
It's okay.
You're the one who's just woken up from a slumber.
What?
I cannot even speak.
English is your second language, right?
It is.
I'm the one that's cooked today.
I actually...
No, you're IGL.
You can't be cooked.
I don't know what to tell you.
I have a G7 scouter if you need it.
Whoa, these are the same guns as before.
What the hell?
I need a triple take though.
I need large guns.
I don't feel confident with G7.
I used to be good with G7 and then they nerfed it a little.
Then they removed the scope for it and then I was like JK, nevermind.
Oh, Gerard, you were not supposed to be there.
Where is he?
You have to go the other way.
There's a longbow here.
I haven't found any shield cells yet.
Let me know if you find a triple take or a scope.
Yep.
Preferably what scope do you want?
2 or 3x.
2 or 3x, yeah.
And a triple take.
We want to just leave here.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
Do you want me to come with you or go up the mountain?
No, we're going to the lava siphon.
I'll craft something.
We want to hit this cache in the blue bin and then go hit the console at the lava siphon.
We want to go fast here.
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
Let's hit this geyser.
Oh, crap.
Go, go, go.
No crafting.
Ah, shit.
No time.
Go, go, go.
It's okay, I'm with you.
I believe in you.
When you're at these redeploys, remember to look up and then look down.
Look as high as you can so you can fly further.
That's how we are able to fly far.
Looks like we're in the next ring.
Alright, alright.
I'm here.
We're here.
We want to just hit the blue bin here and then... oh, someone grabbed that?
I grabbed it but I don't need it.
None of us need it.
Hey, I heard listen to IGL, okay?
That's what I heard.
Alright, we need to just hit this blue bin, go down, grab cache and then go down.
If you guys find more shield cells, let me know.
I only had... I only found four in my...
Oh, I did not.
Yeah, same.
Four and one battery.
Start running guys.
I'm here right behind you.
Oh, there's a care pack here.
We could've played for that.
Oh, it's not down yet.
We can play for it.
Come.
Behind you.
Oh, I found a scope.
I'm fine.
Alright, let's go guys.
Behind you.
Oh, there's a triple take.
I got a two or three scope if you want.
I got a triple take.
It's fine.
Someone might be here.
We might have to fight.
Climb your roof.
I can bubble it whenever.
I'll wait here.
I'll look at the roof.
There's a hemlock here.
I'll take the hemlock.
I'm gonna grab the cache.
Alright, let's go hit this balloon.
I don't know if it was you guys or I heard some sliding.
Oh, wait.
Battery's here.
It's fine.
I'm good.
I need shields.
Just come over.
Let's break this.
Oh, man.
I have 300 ping.
Oh, no.
So far, my ping is 75.
What?
Okay.
So far, keep it that way.
Don't go any higher.
75?
Oh, my god.
No wonder you're teleporting with rides to 300.
Go hit this console, guys.
Console drive?
Just land here.
Just land on this.
You have to bubble him.
Yeah, just do this.
I'll be right behind you.
There's a team here.
I got the bubble.
Okay.
Got it.
I'm here with you.
Okay.
I think we just go ahead and vault here, guys.
Come to me.
Yep.
Going, going, going.
Do you see a 2x4?
Let me know.
Oh,
my god.
Don't get lost.
Just look at the map.
There we go.
Could be people here.
Have to be a bit careful.
Am I gunned out, just in case?
Yep.
I think we're okay.
Cool.
Nice.
We have a cache.
You can grab this.
Alright.
I'll grab the cache.
It's on the left.
Got it.
Let's go.
Backpack.
On me.
Oh, fuck.
Ow, ow, ow.
Son of a bitch.
It's fine.
Mirage is stuck behind this.
Look at him.
Okay, I'm looking.
I hit him.
70.
His teammates are on the left.
I cracked one.
I cracked Mirage again.
Just leave it.
Come back.
Go zone.
I'm gunna die.
Oh, fuck.
Just run.
I'll look for him.
Don't pause.
Running.
Just heal.
Oh, you're in the open.
He's in the open while healing.
Medkit.
Medkit, medkit, medkit.
Just come over here.
We're gunna hit the console here in Typhon.
Okay.
Actually, let's go launch site.
Follow the ping here.
Just follow here.
We might have to fight here.
I think it's okay.
Come with us.
Come, come, come.
Yep, yep, yep.
I'm gunna wait here on the ramp.
I'm gunna look for Gerard.
Alright.
We're gunna look to try and 3-2-1 someone, okay?
Okay.
I'm peeking now.
Just keep walking with me.
No sliding?
I think no one's here.
Oh, no, it's fine.
We can slide.
Come off of there.
Alright.
Gerard, do you need to hit this console again?
Go in zone, go in zone.
Go in zone.
I'm looking for it.
Right here, right here.
Just go in zone and hit it.
We'll keep watch.
We're gunna hit an evac over at the left here.
Okay, yep.
Just come with me.
You can just full heal with syringes, Gerard.
Yep.
More syringes here.
You can take it if you need it.
Okay.
I think we just walk into this building.
Move here?
We're just walking left here.
Yeah, there's people in there.
Okay.
Just keep walking with me.
Go left here, don't slide.
Yeah.
Just crouch here on me.
When they fight, we third party.
Wait.
Just wait a bit, wait a bit.
Yep.
Okay, get close, get close.
Don't slide, don't slide, don't slide.
Okay.
Side now, side now, side now.
He finished, he finished the fight.
Get in, get in, get in.
Okay, all dead.
Nice!
This is one guy left.
Start putting walls up, start putting walls down.
You can.
Yep, yep.
Ow, ow, god, ow.
Owie, that hurt.
It's fine, we have a lot of meds here, so...
Oh, shit, that's fine, whatever.
I don't care, we have so much meds.
There's an ultic cell in here.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Okay, we want to control this whole area.
Okay.
Here, I'm dropping the shield, I'm dropping the health right here, so you guys can know.
We have to be a little bit careful, someone might...
Wait, wait, put a wall in this door, put a wall in this door.
Dread, Dread, Dread, come here, come here, put a wall in this door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I close it?
Yeah, yeah, close it, and then put a wall right here.
Someone might come from the place we've just...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I put a wall there.
Here, I open the door for you.
Yeah, and then put a wall right here again.
Where, where?
No, no, you're fine.
Okay, redo this door, redo this.
Dread, come here.
I think instead of placing the walls inside, you should place the walls outside.
I think we have to...
Okay.
The outside here to hold teams up.
So, where should he post it, place it in?
You can place it, like, on the roof.
Okay.
On the roof above you here.
Wait, wait, redo this.
It's a bit hard to get there.
Yeah, you can climb from the doors.
Okay.
Um, I think you gotta teach him, I don't know which, how to place it.
Uh...
It's a bit hard, but...
You guys wanna play above the roof here.
Okay.
Either above the roof or on that rock.
Okay, Dread, come here.
Um...
Maybe the rock is probably easier to play.
Alright, come with me.
You climb this, and then you place a wall here.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's fine, that's fine.
Is this a good wall?
Bro.
I'm doing double...
Sheila.
Oh, shit.
It's fine, it's fine, I'm okay.
We have, like I said, we have so many shields.
I don't really...
I'm just gonna start putting...
They're landing on us, landing on you guys!
They're coming under!
I'm coming.
I need help, I need help right now.
Oh my god.
I got naded, I got double naded.
Oh, fuck.
I think you gotta play for your life.
You gotta play for your life.
They're all outside, I'm coming around.
Play above, play above.
Play back, play back.
Play back, come back, come back.
They're coming to us.
Come here, come here.
Move back, move back, move back.
Oh my god.
Nice, keep moving to me.
It's fine, it's fine.
I couldn't get inside, what the fuck!
81.
100 to 40.
I'm shield, I'm throwing nades.
Yep.
Can you break the rampart wall?
I have so many nades.
Okay, okay, I'm trying to break.
All the...
48 on the Gibby.
Yep.
I can...
I don't know.
What should we do here?
Back up, back up, back up.
We have a respawn beacon right outside.
Come to me.
I'm right behind you.
I used all my nades.
You need to bubble the...
Oh, frick.
No, no, no, no.
Hold, just hold, just hold.
Okay.
Do you have any syringes?
Yes.
They're pushing us, pushing us.
Outside.
Mirage close.
No, I couldn't.
No!
Did we get kills for that?
Oh, we got one kill, nice.
At least we got two points.
Oh, God.
That puts us at 30.
I don't know how much more we'll need.
We need one more good game.
I couldn't...
I got nade spammed out.
Oh, God.
I was literally stuck in my shield.
I could not get over.
I was trying to hop, but it won't let me.
That's so unfortunate.
Oh, that was the team that fought us earlier, too.
In the tunnels.
The only team running Mirage.
I got nade spammed, so my back was fucked over by nades.
And my front was half-minded.
Yeah, they were just chucking it in.
And then there was a Mirage behind us, too.
So I literally couldn't go anywhere.
Yeah.
I feel like I could have put a bubble, but it's just such a...
We were pinched hard.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait, another team fucking rolled up.
Yeah.
I think it's the team from the left house.
They just pushed.
How could we have played that differently there?
Uh, honestly...
Just, like, not taking too much space.
We just, like...
If we're all three at the house you were at, I think we're okay there.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
So, in, like...
If I'm playing, like, with my team, we would, like, try and hold everything.
But it's, like...
It is really hard to do it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, they won the fight for this house.
Yeah, they took it.
Our house.
I heard that Mirage is, like, the number one Mirage in Japan.
Is he?
Yeah, that's why he only plays Mirage.
At least it wasn't a shit Mirage.
I don't know if he's the number one Mirage in the world.
But, like, I know he's the number one Mirage in Japan.
Like, he literally only plays Mirage.
In every tournament.
I feel honored being killed by...
By the number one Mirage?
Yeah, by the number one Mirage.
At least it wasn't, like, a shit one.
Thank you.
I mean, in this tournament, there's, like, a lot of really, really good things.
But the number one in Japan.
Holy crap.
Number one.
You gotta feel some sort of dignity from that death.
Alright, one last game.
One last game?
Really?
Yeah.
Next game is the last one.
The next one.
We need to do really good then.
No pressure or anything.
No pressure.
How good are we supposed to be in the next one?
I think we need, like, five points, right?
To secure it.
We're at 30 now.
How do we get five points?
Five kills.
Five kills, five points.
Okay, alright.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Five points.
Hell yeah, baby.
We're gonna go for that 5k.
I'm gonna eat some bread.
I didn't have dinner last night.
Oh yeah, you just literally woke up.
You didn't even have fucking breakfast yet.
Eat, eat, eat.
Okay, now we know why we lost.
Because you didn't eat.
I wasn't hungry at all.
Your brain doesn't want to think that.
Just eat, eat.
Your brain's tricking you.
Your brain needs sustenance.
Nutrition.
Yeah.
Just eat something.
Do you have anything over there?
I'm literally eating right now.
Oh, you're eating right now.
Good stuff.
Maybe I should just let go.
Oh my god, we were at Godspot?
Yeah, oh my god.
We were at Godspot.
Yeah, it's literally...
Dude, we set up so much here.
The death boxes were a lot.
No!
We had like a...
We got like a slew of fucking health packs.
And we just...
Aw man, we lost it.
I'm sorry, it happens.
Welcome to Apex Legends, where it's RNG.
Yeah.
And we never even knew this was going to be at Godspot.
No, I'm pretty sure Flame knew.
I'm pretty sure...
GL knew.
I thought it was going to end closer to middle tree, but I knew our spot was going to be really good.
The only thing that makes our spot potentially bad is we don't know which side it's going to go.
And it's like if we can have everything, then like...
We don't need a...
Jesus Christ, this Mirage is freaking crazy, holy shit.
Jesus, he's been sending in clones left and right.
He is psychotic.
I mean, he plays Mirage.
For a one trick.
Of all the characters to one trick, he chose Mirage.
So he's already a little...
He's already wild.
That is a big nightmare.
I wouldn't know who I'm hitting.
That's a lot.
Because I know like back in the early seasons, when you died to a Mirage, people were so mad.
Why?
Because back then Mirage was known as the worst character.
In Apex.
So you died to him, people were just really fucking mad.
Because you're like, I can't believe I died to a Mirage.
So the fact that he chose Mirage to one trick is like a lot.
Jesus.
At one point, I was like the number one Mirage in Canada.
Because I knew how mad people would get when you play Mirage.
Because I was like, I just want to make people angry to die to me.
I mean, he looks pretty fun to use.
Like his ult especially.
Like in panic situations.
This is them fixing Mirage.
To make him a better character.
Because back then, his abilities were so dog shit.
There was like no reason to play him.
What was his ult back then?
His ult was the clones thing.
But you don't go invisible at first.
You just spawn a lot of clones around you.
And you can't control the clones.
So it was useless.
Yeah, you can't control the clones at all.
It was so bad.
I only used the clones.
To do finishers on people.
I had the dancing emote.
So it looks like I back up dancers while I do a finisher.
That's the only reason why I used it.
Because his ult was so bad.
What else do I use it for?
What else do I use his ult for?
This could have been us.
Top 3, this could have been us.
If we killed them in tunnel, they wouldn't have done anything to us.
I almost got one.
I cracked two of them too in tunnel.
I cracked the Mirage.
And then I cracked them again.
And then I'm like, this guy is just sitting on my friend grenades.
I feel like his teammates are going to be the ones that are good.
Now you know.
He's just walking out of zone.
I told you he's fucking wild.
He's wild.
You look so cool.
At least he looked really cool.
My losing streak to Mirage continues.
That's 5 out of 5 now.
Game over.
I'm waiting for the scores to get updated.
To see what the cutoff is.
It's going to be really close, I feel like, the cutoff.
Everybody is literally only a few points away.
Oh my god, I'm refreshing.
Come on, give us the details.
Someone's like, playing Mirage in a tournament is already psychotic.
Bro, this guy, he only plays Mirage in every tournament.
In the last 3 years I've seen him, he's just been Mirage.
Wow.
You recognize his name?
No, I do.
No, he's literally the only Mirage one trick that gets invited to all these tournaments.
So that's why I always know him.
Like, in the JP tournaments.
He literally is the only Mirage one trick that gets invited to all of these tournaments.
So, you know exactly who he is.
God.
I have bad news, guys.
What?
I mean, there's 4 teams on 30 points.
Oh no!
I mean, okay, so...
We need to tiebreak then.
No, we need one good game.
We need points.
How good?
It depends.
But it's possible, like, if the 3 teams at 30 points all get like 10 point games, we could get like 9 points and still lose, you know?
Yeah.
This is scary.
Holy shit.
This is a really high...
Yeah.
So many points are like in the middle.
This is really...
We just have to have a good endgame.
Everyone down to 18th place, if they come top 3, they'll take over as well.
Yeah.
So if we have a bad game here, it's over.
Oh my god.
No pressure.
No pressure, guys.
It's gonna be fine.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna focus 100%.
I was holding back the entire time.
Oh, I know.
Okay, this time.
This time, this time.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, we're starting the server.
Yeah.
Wow.
Wowee.
It's just too bad all the names are in Japanese, because then I could do recognize team names to be like, that team died, so we have a chance.
I can't.
I can't figure it out.
Alright, here we are.
Our last chance, everybody.
The last chance.
This is such a high average, though.
Like a high cutoff.
I was not expecting the cutoff to be this high.
30 points.
It's like our first round, it wasn't that high.
All the points went towards the top 5 teams.
But everyone's doing well.
Yeah.
All we have to do is believe!
We got this.
It's time to believe.
We got this!
Wow.
We made it to elimination round 2, so that's already pretty good.
Yeah.
We fought well.
Alright, let's go, guys.
We're your first charity major?
We did really well.
Thank you.
I think you're the only Hall of Stars member in elimination round 2.
Oh my god.
That is cool.
Which is kind of scary to think about.
So like, you did really well.
I might actually get addicted to this one.
I thought you were gonna say your senpai is gonna beat your ass or something.
I'm afraid of getting addicted and also that.
You don't know.
Like, literally.
Oh my god.
Our Kohai went to the finals.
We didn't know that.
There's a Ult Excel here?
Expectations.
They made it through winner's bracket?
Whoa.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I need a backpack if anyone finds one.
Yep.
I have not come across a fucking shield.
I only have two.
We're just going to here.
You guys can go up the hill again.
Yeah, go up the blue bin.
Both of you guys go up the hill.
Yeah, I'm crafting and then I'll go up.
I have zero backpacks so I'm a little concerned about that for me.
This is a bit rough as well.
Might have to go all the way up the center.
There's a cache.
Wait.
There's a cache in front of me.
No, we can't grab that.
That's too far.
Dread, we need you with me.
Should I grab the blue bin?
I'm worried I'm going to get shot at.
You have to be careful of Siphon because Siphon might come to you.
I don't know.
I can go now.
But if I get down I might meet somebody.
Just go.
I'm literally full sending it now.
If you die, we can craft you somewhere.
Dread, don't follow me.
Just be careful of Siphon.
You don't need to follow me.
Just follow.
Go where Flame is.
Going down.
There's someone ballooning here from Overlook.
He jumped off.
I'm coming over.
Oh no.
Grabbing this cache.
I'm with you.
They're hitting the balloon now.
I'm shooting the last guy.
It's a little bit hard now.
I have no stock on my flatline so I can't participate.
They're flying at us.
They're going to fight us.
Get the high ground.
Climb up the roof.
I'm on it.
No.
I'm coming.
I'm on the roof.
I'm throwing a nade on them.
They're getting shot.
They're going to drop down here.
I cracked on hard.
Careful.
You're by yourself.
One HP.
No.
I'm here.
They're all low.
I'm climbing outside.
No, we can't.
I'm backing up.
They're pushing.
We have to back out.
We're getting pushed by four different teams.
You have to live.
You have to play for life.
There's no team.
They're running for you.
Right here.
We are dead.
I can't believe the other team pushed us.
It's unfortunate.
There's four teams.
Three teams showed up.
I don't know who this team that ran at me is but they threw their game trying to kill me.
They lived though.
Yeah.
They eliminated the strongest people in the game really early.
I understand.
The Valk was 10 HP and the Newcastle was like...
Yeah, I was on the roof so I couldn't push with you.
Yeah.
I think we would have got through it if we won that fight.
The zone might be on us.
I think so.
There was four teams that showed up.
I don't know.
There was literally three teams that showed up.
I think zone does end here.
I think we're just unfortunate.
I'd never think the zone would pull here.
That's really unfortunate.
Yeah, we were out of luck with the zone pull.
We did great, I guess.
Yeah, it was just unlucky we got RNG'd by zone.
Because we had no...
It was not zone.
I don't think zone is here.
It was not zone?
Then why the fuck was everybody here?
I think everyone is here.
I think they're fighting for kill points because they need point kills.
I think we should have definitely been less aggressive if we knew that.
I mean, they flew at us.
We could have still ran back.
The only place we could have run to would have been tunnel.
If we ran anywhere else, we would have ran into a different team.
Yeah, there was a team that appeared from tunnel.
Was there?
Yeah, I saw a team that emerged there and there was a team at the mountain that came from... there was a team that came from monument and then there was a team that came from overlook and there was a team that came from the tunnel and they all pincered us there.
Oh yeah, that's horrible.
We were sandwiched.
Yeah, I think if we stayed in a house, maybe we could have lived, maybe.
And then they just had to pick a team to fight.
It's just hindsight.
Honestly.
That's the way for tournaments.
It's all just hindsight.
Damn, that was the most anticlimactic way to get fucking lost.
I thought we'd be having like a last stand like a top ten or something.
We just got... now we got ran at.
We got ran at by a team.
I mean, I expected better.
God, no.
We got ran at by four teams.
There was nothing we could do.
There's literally nothing we can do there.
I thought we were going to main character this stuff, man.
Yeah, and then when they ran at me, I literally had to heal from aggressing on the other team.
Oh my god, is this the same Mirage or is this a different Mirage?
No, there's only one Mirage.
There's literally only one Mirage.
Oh my god, so this is...
Oh my god.
Oh, you're watching the Mirage?
I'm watching a different team.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
God.
I'm watching the Mirage.
Yeah, I'm also watching the Mirage.
I'm watching the team that third partied.
Oh, the team that third partied is shooting at the Mirage team right now.
Yo, yo, yo!
A bunch of bubbles.
Oh!
Goodbye.
Goodbye, guy.
Oh shit, oh shit, are they gonna lose?
Oh, one team down!
Well, this guy...
No, the other team only has two players alive.
Oh, wait, never mind, it's 2v2.
Yep, 2v2, 2v2.
Oh, it was nice playing with you guys.
Yeah, it was great playing with you!
Thank you for inviting me, Doki.
Appreciate it.
That was genuinely fun.
Thank you for inviting me last minute.
I mean, we made it really far!
We made it really far for like...
I came in with an expectation coming 20th.
And we got a lot better than 20th.
Yeah, I mean, yeah.
We actually did really, really well.
Like, with everything going against us, I mean, to be fair, we even got like, you know, we missed out on the drop spot POI too.
Oh my god.
We don't talk about that.
I mean, the fact that we made it this far without the POI we wanted, that's fine too.
I mean, we started off strong, like top 10s.
My god, that was great.
Yeah, like just every other team also started incredibly strong too, so...
Yeah.
It's just like at the last thing, like we just need one more.
It's like whenever we just say that, we just fumble immediately.
We need just one more update, guys!
One more, and then...
Oh god, we keep just...
Yeah, it's just the way it is.
It is what it is.
Yeah.
That's the thing about tournaments.
You just don't know what's gonna happen.
Anything can happen.
And like, we made it to this far, guys, and we don't have to play day 3.
Isn't that great?
Yeah, you're right!
I'm finally free from this tournament!
I was gonna say, dude.
At least you can play Marvel Rivals now.
Yay!
You don't have to play day 3.
Awesome, awesome.
I was worried, honestly, for Flame because yesterday he was panicking about like, oh my god, I have to push so many things for my schedule.
Like, oh my god, how tough is the schedule gonna be after this?
Oh my god!
I just saw the Valk fucking die to a zone and all.
Yeah.
Oh my god, this poor team.
They didn't make it.
This poor fucking team.
Oh no, Mirage!
Oh, the Mirage is dead?
Oh, that was the team!
There's no heat shields!
Well, it's over.
It's over.
Unless...
Oh, they can.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
Wait, are they gonna actually win?
No, no.
They could.
How far is the zone?
Pretty far.
They have two support.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I thought this was a fight.
Oh no!
What's he been doing?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Ping!
Oh no!
They can't blame on Ping!
They can't blame on Ping because they're literally literally in Japan.
They're not us.
Listen, I think we had an average Ping of like 200 to 300.
Yeah, it depends on how your internet feels like.
My internet is also like insanely bad.
It's like 200 to 300.
How do you do championship scrims then?
Uh, yeah.
Probably like 250 to 300.
Yeah, holy...
Holy bad here.
Yeah, I was gonna say, how the fuck do you survive those scrims without Ping?
Oh, they're fucked.
There's a team in the tunnel.
Guess I'm not subscribing to that fucking exit lag.
I mean, it was a free trial, so you'd be fine.
Yeah.
You never had to pay anything again anyway.
Yo, they survived!
I thought they were gonna die.
They actually made it.
Oh my god, what happened to the team in the tunnel?
Oh no, there was... Oh no, there is.
They're still there.
Oh my god!
I think it's two master players.
No, no, Mirage is Pred.
I think it's a Pred master player.
Wait, no, there's no way their point system doesn't work like that.
There's no way they can get a master player with their point system.
Cause I'm considered a Pred.
Even though I'm like super fucking washed.
Two Preds...
A Pred and a master is like definitely less points than... Oh, cause yeah, you're LGS pro.
Yeah, yeah, I forgot.
They're not, so they can fit a master in.
Oh my god, they lived.
The Pathfinder is doing the best.
What?
Oh my god, he's...
Oh shit, you're right!
He's a triple Pred player.
I think it's two Preds.
Yeah.
He's max level already.
But the thing is, they have...
Wait, no, this guy has more points cause he's a recent Pred too.
Cause like my points are 12 for a season 4 Pred.
His Pred badges, I think his most recent one is like less than season 9.
That does not look like a recent badge, I don't think.
Yeah, but still, he looks like a guy that plays very consistently.
I play every, like various FPS games, I do not play Apex consistently anymore.
There's options for me.
I mean, you've been playing for a long time, so...
I have, I have.
That's why I don't...
Yeah, but like these guys have been playing a long time, plus consistently.
Ooh.
And I've been on third person too.
Hey, most of them are streamers, right?
I think they're like...
All the players here are content creators.
Oh, hell yeah.
Content creators are pros.
No wonder.
Yeah, this is a content creator lobby.
So I was like, what if the other two teams didn't get any points?
Guys, there's teams below us that can also get points.
Like, yeah, but guys, you gotta remember, the other teams also can get points.
Yeah.
The only way we can do this is only if the top 9 teams get points These are the only ones that get points, that's it.
Everybody else doesn't get any points.
Wait, is the Mirage team gonna win again?
I think they are.
Dude, they... Yo!
I mean, I feel like I want the Mirage team to win, just so they can get the lead, like, they can farm all the points.
Honestly.
Our best bet is if they farm all the points.
Oh, never mind.
Goodbye, Gibraltar.
No, they can rat this out.
Oh my god, that Pathfinder was so lucky.
That Pathfinder got the bad off at the right time.
Oh, well, oh god.
Battery, battery, please.
Pathfinder, please.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Oh!
Nice!
Crack!
Holy shit.
They're fucking alive?
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo!
God damn.
Mirage.
He's just jumping around with his clones.
No one knows what to do.
They're just like, which one's the real one?
The thing is, this Mirage knows when he has the clones, he can play more dangerously because they're like, who do I shoot?
Yeah.
Like, look at that Mirage, he's fucking going in.
Oh, and he's dead.
He literally has one life.
Oh, Jk, there's his life's gone.
He literally gambled that.
He was like, they're not gonna shoot me.
You have to figure out like, oh, is he actually gonna shoot me or not?
And the Pathfinder can't rez that because he's not a support character.
Fuck, really?
Oh, oh.
It's too risky for him.
Shit.
Oh my god.
I didn't know there were plays in like, uh, reviving.
I mean, I think he's pretty clear.
No one's- oh!
No, he is not clear.
Oh.
Oh, nine more teams.
Yeah, nine more squads until this tournament is officially over for us.
I hope all the teams that pushed us in that one area died.
That's all I want in life.
I hope so too.
Those four teams that fucking pushed us, I hope they never- I hope they didn't get to play the game.
Why are you so toxic?
Oh my god.
Did you not remember what just happened to us?
I hope they just fucking don't make it.
Literally, we were not in zone.
This was not end zone, and we had four teams ran at us.
They were so aggressive.
I get to be toxic over that.
That was the most dumbest shit you could do.
Yeah, not gonna lie.
Why specifically during the end game you had to fuck us up like that?
Yeah, I kinda get it.
The fact that we had four teams that did that to us.
I'm like, this is not end team, this is not end zone.
Why are you here?
It's just a little drill.
Why?
They just heard gunshots.
They were hoping to be the team that made it out.
All four of them were like, we're gonna be the team that makes it out of here.
And grab all those KP.
I want them all to suffer and watch the game like us.
Just all the way through.
This is quite a sit through.
What?
This is a fucking scary end game though.
I mean, the guy in the tower, I think he has the most advantage.
No one would try to get up there.
End game is next to them too.
Is it?
I think my minimap is bugged.
Wait, really?
I don't know, I can't see where it's ending.
It's ending right next to the people on the high ground.
Really?
How do you guys see that?
You see the line on the top left, right?
Uh huh.
So you see where it ends at?
My line is ending there as well, but I'm pretty sure it's a bug with spectator.
Wait, really?
So that's not end game?
The line moves with the guy, if you see.
Oh, does it?
If the point where the line goes doesn't move with the guy, then I can't tell because he's not moving that much.
Do they have a solid spot?
I don't know.
I think it is.
Everybody's converging there though.
See, everyone's converging there.
It's just the problem is when they changed the algorithm like a while back Oh my god, the Pathfinder is cooking.
They changed the algorithm a while back where it adds like hard pull to one side of the zone.
Like it'll always bias towards the middle.
Why did they drop off high ground?
Wait, what?
I'm pretty sure the zone doesn't end on them.
Oh, it doesn't?
Yeah.
I was like, why did they drop down?
You're so close to...
Yeah, I guess it wasn't Yeah, it wasn't.
Oh, they got top Q though from that thing.
To be fair, they were 1 HP.
They were 1 HP.
Like, what the fuck can you do?
GG's everybody.
GG's.
Good game!
Not really though because that was fucking pathetic.
It was fun to watch.
It was good to watch.
It was a good game to watch though.
Other than the part where the Pathfinder grappled over.
Yeah.
Well, that was it everybody.
Hope you guys enjoyed the tournament experience.
Yeah, for your first tournament you did really well, Gerard.
For your first tournament.
We made it so far though.
That's the thing.
We had a lot of fun.
Yeah, we had a lot of fun.
We get to watch Gerard run.
We weren't really aiming for literally this position.
Yeah, we never...
None of us thought we would make it this far.
That's the thing.
Yeah, and we kept on believing.
That's what matters.
Yeah, and we had some good games too.
And we had some great moments like Gerard running into a team when we said go die.
That was...
I need to know what team that was that he ran at.
Like, I am very curious.
I need to know what they were thinking when they saw this guy fucking run at them.
God, that was horrible.
That was a great moment.
That woke me up.
That actually made me lock in the next couple of games after.
No, Gerard disabled the replay.
He disabled the replay.
You want me to turn it on?
I can turn it on.
We needed three points, Flame.
We needed three?
We needed three points and we would have made it.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
We literally just needed three.
Jesus.
If we killed that team in the house, we'd probably win the tiebreaker.
Yeah, we literally were the only 30 point team that didn't get points.
Yeah, that's tough.
That was the most unlucky thing that could have happened to us.
All the 30 point teams got points.
Oh, we were so close.
That's fine though.
We were really close.
We made it really far.
And we're free tomorrow.
We don't have to wake up at really...
I don't have to wake up.
I'm free tomorrow now, except for my conventions.
Woo!
What convention was that?
I don't know where it is in America, but it's...
It's somewhere in America, guys.
Check it out.
Just go somewhere in America.
It's in Florida, guys.
I'll be there in Florida tomorrow.
Virtually.
GGs.
I had a great time playing with you guys.
Yeah, thank you.
I appreciate the invite.
Yeah, now you'll be less stressed for LGS flame after playing with Juraj and I.
You'll be...
I love my teammates, Mel.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you're gonna appreciate your teammates so much more.
You're like, when you say go time, Lisa will not do that.
Oh my god, we're getting things done.
Oh my god, what?
You're just like, whoa, that was such...
Oh my god, you don't need to tell them where to put your walls.
You've been so traumatized by the tournament.
You learn to love your teammates after.
That was fun, though.
GG.
I'm happy to play with you guys.
Thank you for accepting my invite to this tournament.
Thank you, thank you.
GGs, everybody.
GGs.
I hope we get to play again in the future.
Thank you, thank you.
If by chance we get to meet each other, it's gonna be a fight.
You should come to Japan.
What do you mean, a fight?
Come to Japan!
Drinks are on me.
You should come to Japan.
Hey, yeah, you're right.
Are you running Japan, Doki?
Maybe.
I can't say it on stream if I am or not.
So let's just say maybe.
Alright.
I may be there, might not be there.
Who knows?
I can't confirm or deny it.
What do you mean by that?
I don't like telling people exactly where I'm going.
I like that people think there's a...
I might not be there.
It's a mystery.
It's always a mystery.
So yeah.
You just get off on the suffering of other people.
Yeah.
They'll always be like, Whoa, what's gonna happen?
Is she going or is she not?
We don't know.
They're just fighting the right time.
I'll eventually be in Japan at one point.
But we don't know if it's five years, ten years, a couple of months.
We'll never know.
Same here, who knows?
Alright.
GGs, guys.
I had so much fun.
I think this has to be the least...
This was definitely the least stressful tournament for me of this year.
Because of us?
Because of...
Because honestly, the things Jirard does it just...
Puts me out of it.
It made me realize I was like...
Whenever you do something, I was like...
I'm just like...
This is not as serious as I thought it was.
It's not stressful!
It doesn't feel...
It's good because I'm not stressed.
I'm not stressed playing this tournament.
You get the vibes.
I'm just not as serious.
You're welcome.
I walk in, but I'm not stressed out.
You're welcome, I guess.
Thank you.
I think Flame is stressed out though.
I would say I'm a little bit stressed out.
Don't look at my stream, guys.
Let's relive this moment.
Flame, you have to save his ass every time.
I just watch.
I just get to watch it happen.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
Look at my stream, guys.
Look at my stream on Discord.
Let's relive this legendary moment.
You gotta watch what I saw.
When the VOD is over, you guys gotta watch what I saw.
It's actually so fucking funny.
My POV of it is so funny.
You told me to die!
I had no choice!
I got the overview of both of you.
I'm dead.
At least we got free armor points from him dying again there.
I like how you rewinded it, too.
I fucking hate this.
I thought that's what you meant!
God damn it.
No...
I mean, at least it was enjoyable for all of you, I guess.
Yeah, it was very enjoyable.
I had a great time.
No, thank you for making...
I had a great time as well.
Thank you for making me actually a little bit better.
Like, throughout this sermon, I've been learning a lot from both of you.
Yeah, you're absorbing...
Yeah, now you're just gonna be a Rampart main right after that.
Yeah, actually.
Legit.
I don't know.
I could see it going either way.
Either he becomes a Rampart main, or he's too traumatized to ever touch it again.
No!
I actually like it!
Like the strats at endgame.
Like, Jesus, I love the strats that you guys think of.
It's awesome.
It's a nice investment.
Yeah, now you know.
And you did really well for your first tournament.
My first tournament, I didn't do that well.
Yeah, like, thank you for giving me my first champion.
Yeah, your very first champion against other Pred players, too.
And Pred and Pros, that's really good.
In fact, you actually killed Pro players.
You actually killed a Pro player during that 1v3.
One of them was a Pro.
Yeah!
Yeah, I know!
Yeah, he 1v3'd a Pro!
Dude, I cringed, like, I watched a VOD, and like, I could've, I should've, like, re-batteried myself, and like, healed, and went outside, but I was like, full on adrenaline.
Yeah, you were just dying.
I did not look at my HP.
Like, I was so hyped, like, YAY!
SQUAD WIPE!
Ran outside, got shot.
He was just like, I did it!
And then, fuck you, shot.
He literally got shot the moment you came out.
Dude, I was like, are you guys proud of me?
Look what I just did!
Look what I...
But that won't happen ever again.
Because that never happened here.
It never did.
I was gonna say something really fucked up.
What the fuck?!
It's not gonna happen again, because you're not invited.
I'm joking.
Don't invite me to these things ever again.
If I need points, need someone who's under the point threshold, you got my DM.
I'll never play rank ever again.
You have to!
You have to not play rank ever again.
You gotta be my bronze player.
I'm just gonna be playing pubs forever.
I mean, I'm alright with it.
I don't actually, like, play rank all the time.
I just, like, like to chill.
Not all the time I get to play anyway.
Wait, Flame, you gotta post that clip of your POV of the...
You gotta tweet it.
You gotta tweet that clip.
I'm gonna retweet the shit out of it, I swear.
Do it right now, I'll retweet it.
Somebody can also clip my POV of everything, and then so we can all see, like...
Someone clip your POV, my POV, and Flame's POV.
And then Flame will post his own POV, and then we can see the whole fucking shitshow happen.
We got different angles of it!
I mean, I'll send you guys my POV if you want it.
No, no, you gotta post it on Twitter, Flame.
No, Flame, post it on Twitter, Flame!
No, you do it!
You do it!
You'll get so many retweets and, like, think about that, Flame.
Dude, you're gonna be so famous after this.
Dude, do that right now!
Yeah, come on, do it right now!
Post that clip!
We're not leaving until you post the clip right now.
And we can retweet it live.
I did.
I mean, my problem...
It's not that I don't want to post the clip, it's just that it takes a long time to, like...
Just clip it!
Just snip it!
Yeah, we have the time, we'll just sit here, bro.
Yeah, we'll sit here until you do it.
Oh, and somebody made the clip!
Okay, here's...
Somebody made my clip, my POV.
You guys gotta see this POV.
I posted it in the Doki Bird channel.
I'm retweeting it.
Okay, this...
Yeah, I'm just gonna retweet this.
Wait, did you guys retweet it already?
I retweeted mine, yeah.
Oh shit, let me retweet it too!
Oh my god!
My POV was fucking crazy!
It's so horrible to look at!
No!
My embarrassment again?
No, no...
Oh my god...
Again!
You told me to die!
Anyone who's watching me right now, you told me to die!
You wanted me to die so we could pick you up!
You kept picking me up in the middle of nowhere!
I don't know!
My brain!
I thought you understood me!
Oh no, oh god...
Oh no...
Oh my god...
I literally had the perfect POV for all of that.
Okay, that was painful.
Anyway, anything else?
Other than that?
We just need to wait until Flame posts his POV too.
So we have three POVs at the moment.
No Flame, you have to!
You have to!
Flame!
Come on Flame!
Flame, it'll be so funny!
Flame, come on!
Your POV actually fixes a lot of things!
Come on, come on.
Your POV makes everything...
Yeah, it makes everything even better.
It unites all of us.
You gotta post it on Twitter.
Just from your eyes seeing the horror just running straight to the enemy?
I wanna see that!
We wanna have immortalized on Twitter.
Something to remember, you know?
You said so yourself!
Yeah, exactly!
There were so many moments, but I think this was the one.
This is the time.
This was the best moment.
Out of all the moments, this was the moment in Apex Legends.
Forget the top three.
This is the moment.
Forget the championship, this was the moment!
Don't forget that!
This one!
I'm just looking at your POV, Dokkaebi.
I'm still replaying that!
I see like...
You're playing fucking acrobatic tap stream trying to fucking save your ass.
You're just trying to keep me alive!
And then I tripped again!
No, that's good that you tripped again.
That's another plus 30.
Oh yeah, you're right!
We needed that.
It added to the content.
Yeah, it added to it.
Are you uploading it now?
Come on.
Come on, Flynn.
I know how clipping is so fast.
I'm literally clipping in your profile right now.
I'm just reloading it.
I have to like...
Wait, I have to run it through a different app.
Wait, what?
The export on the...
Like...
The thing that I use, I think it's .mkv.
The file is in .mkv.
And I have to like...
Change it.
Because on mkv there's a limit of like...
Try trimming it and then saving it as...
Yeah, that's what I'm doing now.
Yeah, you trim it and then the export is so fast after that.
Yeah, I just...
You don't have to open...
Premiere or something.
I believe.
I believe, Flynn.
It takes a long time to figure this out.
Okay, don't worry.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'll stay in the call, but I'm gonna go offline.
But it's fine.
Okay, okay.
Alright guys, thank you.
Oh my god, your last post was October 3.
And you're...
And the first thing you post after that...
Is just that.
We have to.
You have to.
Does anyone have the Gerard clip?
So then we can at least like...
We have the three POVs...
Of that exact moment.
Can't wait to end my POV.
Holy crap, I can't wait.
Thank you guys for watching.
I'm staying in the call so I know...
Flame is actually gonna upload it.
I need it.
I don't want him to like...
Pussy out on this one.
Yeah, me too.
I don't want him to pussy out.
I'm gonna stay in the call.
I wanna be there to see everything.
Wait, you got it?
Dude, do it.
Wait, you got the trim?
You got it?
Yeah, I got it.
Oh shit, okay.
Don't worry, I'll be there live.
I'm camping, I'm reloading.
We're all gonna witness this live.
And then Gerard just has to end his stream so his clippers can get the clip.
For the final POV.
The final piece of the puzzle.
Yeah, the final piece of the puzzle is Gerard.
Guys, does anyone know which team it is?
So then we can have the...
Somebody can clip the team's POV that we were shooting at.
Oh yeah, you're right.
The one you were like shooting at me.
Yeah, yeah.
If anybody knows the exact team that saw it...
And then someone clip their reaction.
It would be so funny if they were so flabbergasted.
Like, what the fuck is that guy doing?
He's just running down without any armor?
We need the fourth POV of the enemy team.
Just to see the whole mess that it came to be.
You guys are watching the tournament, right?
Like, check out.
I want you guys to spy on every one of them's POVs, please.
Yeah, yeah.
The fourth POV of the incident.
The fucking incident.
The incident.
I'm not seeing any uploads, bro.
I'm still reloading it.
His brother is dedicated.
He'll charge in with no question asked.
The real soldier.
A true soldier.
Yeah.
Good soldiers follow orders.
You told me to listen to him.
He knows better.
And I immediately followed.
Use your head to figure out what it means.
Well, I did.
You said die.
Am I ready to go?
I didn't realize Blaine had to be specific about, like, stand here and just die.
I just wanted to get out there and die.
That's the only thing.
Get out there and die.
Okay, I'm going.
I don't know.
I'm an apex virgin.
I don't know any of this.
I barely had any experience.
The plan versus execution.
The plan versus execution meme.
It went so horrible.
But it was so funny.
It worked out in the end.
You didn't fully die.
At least you got something out of that, right?
Yeah.
We got content.
We got double res, dude.
It was part of a master plan.
We got double the amount of points.
Well, at least.
My throat hurts from laughing.
Honestly, I don't think anybody had a better clip moment than that moment.
Throughout this entire tournament.
Everyone was just so serious and it's just us.
That was actually the best moment in this entire tournament.
I don't think anybody experienced what we just experienced.
I mean, to be fair, I'm the only bronze player.
I don't think anyone was crazy enough like me to put a bronze player in this lobby.
Silver and gold probably, but not a fucking bronze.
They're like, chug it, gold player, right?
And I was like, fuck it.
I don't know anybody that's gold or silver.
Let's go after Arden here.
Literally last pick from the playground.
That's literally what happened.
When we made it far.
We made it so far.
I know.
We made it further than other teams that had really stacked teams.
Teams that had three master players or masters and diamond players.
We probably did scrims too, right?
Oh yeah, 100%.
No, they did scrims.
We did not do scrims.
Maybe scrims would have helped us out.
It was literally six hours before the tournament, I think.
No, it was not six hours.
I asked you 14 hours before the tournament.
It was literally last fucking minute.
If it was six hours, I'd be really fucked.
Oh my God.
Literally, after I ended my 11-hour stream, I saw your message and was like, holy fuck.
Tomorrow?
Okay, Saturday, I can do it.
And then I woke up literally the next day.
Holy shit, it's in four hours.
The tournament has been in four hours.
And my manager was like, what the fuck are you doing?
Wait, you uploaded it?
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh my God, you're finally active on social media again.
Oh my God, incredible.
Shout out to my dude.
When I say jump, he says, how high?
This is his POV.
Oh my God, I'm going to link it.
I want everybody to watch this.
Here, I'm going to put it in my chat.
I like how Flame was dodging every bullet just to save your ass.
There.
If everyone's watching right now, just check out the link that I put in the chat.
Go look at it.
I like how they have no context because it's a three-minute delay, so they just see it as random.
They just see it as a link.
It's like a random link.
It's just POV.
Actually, I think it took so long for me to get it out.
This probably comes like just in time, as you were saying.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Upload it now!
Die!
Yes, ma'am.
Oh my God.
Thank you, Gerard.
Thank you.
Now you made Flame appreciate his teammates more.
Big shout -out to you, Gerard.
You made losing fun.
It was all possible to all of you.
Thank you.
You made him appreciate his teammates even more now.
Without you, that wouldn't have happened.
You're gonna hug him really tight after this one.
Flame's team, he managed to get...
was it fourth or third place?
We got third last year.
He got third, yeah.
He got third place in ALGS with a full mouse and keyboard team, Gerard.
And I think this was more stressful than what he had to go through.
I think this exact moment is more stressful than handling a 3M and K team.
I kinda see it.
You had fun, right?
It wasn't stressful, right?
Prove her wrong.
First day was stressful, right?
Compared to the first day.
Both days were fun, though.
Both days were really fun.
Alright, guys.
We need one more.
We just need Gerard's and the enemy team's POV.
Whenever you guys post it.
And then I'll retweet it whenever you guys get it.
We have all the POVs.
We have the full story.
We're documenting everything.
The GG's, guys.
GG's.
I had a fun time.
Good game, everybody.
Good game.
Until the next tournament, if ever that's gonna happen.
Thank you again for joining me.
Thank you, guys.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, Flame.
Oh, it's Saturday.
You don't have scrims.
We're not gonna have scrims for, like, two weeks.
Oh, yeah, because it's a holiday.
Holiday break.
You're free.
Don't forget to follow Doki and Flame.
Thank you so much.
Check them out, guys.
Check them out, everybody.
I'll see you guys then.
I'll see you two later.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
GG's.
Alright, that was fun.
We made it really far.
We were so close to winners.
But honestly, I'm tired.
So, like, it's a blessing in disguise.
Because, like, this is my break week.
Like, after the original is over, I'm just like, you know, that's alright.
I'm okay with not making it to finals.
I get to rest a little bit more tomorrow.
After the convention.
I'm okay with that.
But I had so much fun.
A lot of fun.
And everything was...
It was Sakura's team!
Sakura's team that this happened with.
Oh my god.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching it.
And it was honestly such a great time.
Wait, I need to tell them.
Wait, are they still in the beast or not, right?
I'm going to tell them.
At strafing in, the team that saw all of this was the main organizer team.
Sakura.
The map.
That's so funny.
Holy shit.
Do you know what it means?
We absolutely have the POV.
Anyway, guys.
That was really fun.
I'm happy to play with Jirard.
And playing with Jirard really made the tournament less stressful.
I mean, for me.
Less stressful.
It was...
Oh my god!
It was on the main stream too!
Look at that!
Oh my god.
That's so funny.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the chips.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, say hi to Jirard.
Check him around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!